THE ASSEMBLY LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE HEARING
GOOD TO BE BACK IN PERSON. OF
HOW WE ARE NO LONGER REQUIRING
MASSIVE FOR THE CAPITAL.
CERTAINLY HAVEN'T SET AT THE
DISCRETION OF EVERYONE AS TO
WHAT THEY CHOOSE TO DO A
PHYSICAL DISTANCING IS STILL
REQUIRED THE HEARING ROOM FOR
THOSE IN ATTENDANCE- TRY TO. BE
MINDFUL OF THAT- AND YOU KNOW AS
WE PROCEED WITH THE WITNESSES
AND PUBLIC COMMENT TO MAKE SURE
EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS. THAT THE
ASSEMBLY HAS RULES TO ENSURE WE
MAINTAIN ORDER AND RUN AN
EFFICIENT AND FAIR HEARING. OF
YOU BY THESE RULES TO ALL
HEARING TO ALL PEOPLE WHO
PARTICIPATE IN OUR PROCEEDINGS.
AND IN ORDER TO FACILITATE THE
GOAL OF HEARING AS MUCH OF THE
PUBLIC WITHIN THE LIMITS OF OUR
TIME. I WILL NOT PERMIT THAT
CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS DISTURBS
OTHERWISE IMPEDES ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF LEGISLATIVE
PROCEEDINGS- AND THERE ARE A FEW
OPTIONS. FOR TESTIMONY PRIMARY
WITNESSES WILL BE TESTIFYING IN
PERSON FOR PUBLIC COMMENT THEY
COULD BE IN PERSON OR BY PHONE
AND IF YOU ARE OF. OF EITHER
CALLING IN OR IN PERSON
PROVIDING PUBLIC COMMENT WE
STATE THAT YOU SIMPLY STATE YOUR
NAME ORGANIZATION IF ANY AND
POSITION ON THE BILL. THE CALL
NUMBER FOR PUBLIC COMMENT IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR FOUR SEVEN I'LL REPEAT
THAT COLIN NUMBER. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR FOUR
SEVEN. YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY LABOR
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE- ALE BR. DOT
ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT GOV- AS WELL
AS ON YOUR TV SCREEN FOR THOSE
THAT ARE WATCHING THE TELECAST.
FIVE YOU'RE CALLING IN- PLEASE
PLAN TO DO SO AS- THE AUTHOR OF
THE BILL YOUR TEST FOR THE BILL
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO SPEAK TO IN
TERMS OF PUBLIC COMMENT. IS
BEGINNING THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION THE PERATOR
OPERATOR LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE PLACED
IN QUEUE BASED ON WHETHER YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE A BILL-
CERTAINLY ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE INCLUDING WHAT
READING YOUR LIVE STREAM
BROADCASTS- WHEN YOU MAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT. ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE
MODERATE A PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN
CALL THE COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE
SIX THREE ONE NINE. TWO ZERO
NINE ONE AGAINST 916-319-2091 MY
STAFF WILL BE THERE. TRY TO
HELP. I ALSO WANNA NOTE THE- WE
AS ALWAYS ACCEPTING WITNESSES-
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH THE
PRISON POSITION LETTER PORTAL.
ON THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. AND
WE ALSO HAVE. AN EMAIL. ADDRESS
SET UP THAT YOU CAN USE TO EMAIL
US. YOUR COMMENTS AND POSITIONS
ON ANY THE LEGISLATION- EMAIL IS
A L. B. R. DOT COMMITTEE AT
ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT GEO BEE
AGAIN L. B. R. DOT COMMITTEE AT
ASSEMBLY DOT C. A. DOT GLV. I'M
BEFORE WE TAKE WALL MAKE.
NOTABLE BEING. WELCOMING TWO
MEMBERS. APPOINTED BY THE
SPEAKER FOR TODAY'S HEARING
ONLY. ACTUALLY THREE OF TODAY'S
HEARING ONLY A SERVER A BIGELOW
REPLACING- SUMMER FLORIDA.
THAT'S IN ROUTE THIS SUMMER
CARILLO INSTILLING A DEMOCRATIC
VACANCY SHE'LL BE HERE SHORTLY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN REPLACING
AS A MEMBER SEYARTO SO WELCOME
JOHN. GOOD TO HAVE YOU HERE. ALL
RIGHT AND- SO YES WE'RE GONNA BE
TAKING BILLS IN. FILE ORDER. AND
WE ARE READY TO PROCEED WITH
FOR- YEAH IF WE CAN- IF MASS X.
RAY COULD TAKE ROLLER IN ORDER
TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM IT'S BEEN
AWHILE. THANK YOU. KALRA YEAH
BIGELOW JONES SAWYER FOR THE
REYES CHEN YOUR WORD THERE
CARILLO. ONE SO WE DO HAVE
QUORUM ESTABLISHING WILL WAIT
OTHER MEMBERS AS THEY SHOW UP-
AND WE'LL GO AHEAD TO BILL ITEM
ONE WHICH IS AB SIXTEEN OH ONE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER WHO IS
HERE AND LOOKS LIKE READY TO GO. AND SO THIS IS A SB SIX ONE IT
DOES HAVE. THE IN IRAQ- DO
PASTOR PROBES- A DOCK WEBER
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE. I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB
SIXTEEN OH ONE THE STATE
CALIFORNIA CALL CENTER JOBS ACT.
A BILL TO PROTECT CALIFORNIANS
CALL CENTER WORKERS AND STOP THE
CURRENT PRACTICE OF CORPORATIONS
REAPING THE BENEFIT OF STATE
FUNDING AND SUBSIDIES WHAT THE
SAME TIME EXPORTING JOBS
OVERSEAS. CALL CENTERS ARE A
MAJOR ECONOMIC FORCE AND THE U.
S. REPRESENTING ABOUT 3% OF OUR
WORKFORCE. YET THE NUMBER OF
CUSTOMER SERVICE AND CONTRACT
SENATE JOBS HAVE DECLINED IN THE
LAST FOUR YEARS BY FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND. LARGELY DUE TO
OUTSOURCING AND LAYOFFS. IT HAS
BECOME ALL TOO COMMON FOR
CORPORATIONS TO REAP THE
BENEFITS OF STATE FUNDING AND
SUBSIDIES WHAT THE SAME TIME
EXPORTING JOBS OVERSEAS. FOR
EXAMPLE OUR SALES AND USE TAX
EXCLUSION PROGRAM AWARDS A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS EACH
YEAR TO ELIGIBLE COMPANIES WHO
HAVE CALL CENTERS LOCATED IN
CALIFORNIA AND PROMOTE
ALTERNATIVE ENERGY AND ADVANCED
TRANSPORTATION. THESE OFFSHORING
PRACTICES HAVE DEVASTATING
IMPACTS ON COMMUNITIES AS THEIR
ONCE GOOD PAYING JOBS ARE TAKEN
AWAY. CALIFORNIA MUST PROTECT
HARD WORKING WOMEN AND MEN
EMPLOYED IN CALL CENTERS AND
CORPORATIONS. STE AND
CORPORATION SHOULD NOT REAP
THESE BENEFITS IF THEY OUTSOURCE
THEIR JOBS. CALIFORNIA IS
CURRENTLY BEHIND OTHER STATES
SUCH AS NEW YORK CONNECTICUT NEW
JERSEY ALABAMA NEVADA AND
LOUISIANA WHO HAVE ALL TAKEN
ACTION AND ENACTED COMMONSENSE
REFORMS TO ENSURE TAXPAYERS ARE
NOT LEFT FOOTING THE BILL WHEN
CORPORATIONS MOVE THEIR JOBS
OVERSEAS. AB SIXTEEN NO ONE IS A
JOB AND TAX PAYER PROTECTION
MEASURE THAT REQUIRES EMPLOYERS
TO GIVE THE LABOR COMMISSIONER A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY DAYS NOTICE
WHEN RELOCATING 30% OR MORE OF
THEIR CALL CENTER JOBS FROM
CALIFORNIA. TO ANOTHER COUNTRY.
IN ADDITION THESE EMPLOYERS
WOULD BE PROHIBITED FROM
RECEIVING STATE GRANTS
GUARANTEED LOANS OR TAX CREDITS
FOR FIVE YEARS. THIS BILL WOULD
ALSO REQUIRE STATE AGENCIESWILL
CONTRACT OUT FOR CALL CENTRE
SERVICES TO PERFORM AT LEAST 90%
OF THE SERVICES AND THE STATE.
THIS BILL IS SUPPORTED BY THE
COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF AMERICA
AND A SPONSORED BY THE
AND SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE FOR RETIRED AMERICANS
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION. CALIFORNIA STATE
LEGISLATIVE BOARDS SMART
TRANSPORTATION DIVISION AND THE
UNITED STEELWORKERS DISTRICT
TWELVE. HERE TO SPEAK WITH ME
TODAY. IS A NICE YOUR HERNANDEZ
REPRESENTING THE COMMUNICATION
WORKERS OF AMERICA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER-CHAIRMAN BIRDS ARE NOT HERNANDEZ
ON BEHALF OF THE COMMUNICATION
WORKERS OF AMERICA DISTRICT NINE
WHICH ENCOMPASSES CALIFORNIA
NEVADA AND HAWAII WE ARE THE
SPONSORS OF THE BILL I THANK DR
WEBER FOR AUTHORING THIS
LEGISLATION- YOU KNOW THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF TALKING
LEGISLATURE ABOUT JOB CREATION
JOB RETENTION IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- INSTEAD IN
PARTICULAR. TRYING TO PRESERVE
JOBS THAT- THAT HELP INDIVIDUALS
WITH A LIVING WAGE AND ALSO TO
ALLOW THEM TO SUPPORT THEIR
FAMILIES AND CALL CENTER JOBS
REALLY ARE CAREER TYPE JOBS- LOT
OF CBA WORKERS HAVE BEEN A CALL
CENTERS FOR TEN FIFTEEN TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY YEARS. SO IT
IS REALLY A WAY FOR THEM TO
ESTABLISH A CAREER TAKE CARE OF
THEIR FAMILIES- HERE IN THE
STATE AND AS WE STATED EARLIER
IT'S A FORTUNATE THERE HAS BEEN
A GROWING. NUMBER OF JOBS BEING
MOVED BOTH OUT OF STATE AND
OVERSEAS- THERE WERE SOME CALL
CENTERS CLOSED IN ANAHEIM
BAKERSFIELD ATWATER SACRAMENTO
OAKLAND AND THE SIGNIFICANT
REDUCTIONS IN CALL CENTER
EMPLOYEES AND SAN RAMON FRESNO
SAN DIEGO COMMERCE PASADENA
ESCONDIDO IN TORRANCE IS JUST
SOME EXAMPLES OF THE LAST FEW
YEARS. AND THESE JOBS CONTINUE
TO BE MOVED- AND IT THIS IS BOTH
IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR AND IN THE
PUBLIC SECTOR CONTRACTS FOR
PUBLIC ENTITIES. NOT SO THIS
BILL IS NOT A WHOLE SET OF
RESTRICTIONS ON OUTSOURCING WHAT
THIS DOES IS REALLY AS WAS
STATED EARLIER PROTECT TAXPAYER
MONEY IN ENSURE THAT TAXPAYER
DOLLARS ARE USED TO SUBSIDIZE
JOBS HERE IN CALIFORNIA. COUPLE
THINGS I WANT TO POINT OUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA UP UNTIL A
FEW YEARS AGO REQUIRED ALL
CONTRACTS FOR CALL CENTER JOB
SUPPORT STATE AND ENTITIES STATE
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS TO BE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS OKAY CONTRACT
TERMS WERE LOOSENED AND
EVENTUALLY THEY'LL THEY WERE
GONE SO THAT NOW THOSE VENDORS
COULD CAN'T TAKE THOSE JOBS THE
OTHER STATES- AND SO THAT'S
THAT'S A PROBLEM- AND ALSO YOU
KNOW. THE PRIVATE SECTOR THESE
COMPANIES DID HAVE THE JOBS HERE
IN CALIFORNIA BEFORE MOVING THEM
OVERSEAS SO IT CAN BE DONE WE
DID TALK WITH CW WAY AND THE
LEGISLATURE NEW YORK SINCE THERE
LAWS. ADOPTING LAWS AFTER
SLIGHTLY STRONGER THAN THAN THE
LANGUAGE WE HAVE HERE- AND THEY
SAID IT'S BEEN WORKING IN FACT
WHAT THEY HAVE BEEN SEEN AS AN
UPTICK IN JOBS IN CALL CENTER.
JOBS IN THE STATE OF NEW YORK
AND WE THINK THAT WOULD BE A-
MAJOR BENEFIT HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AGAINST JUST INSURING. OUR
PUBLIC DOLLARS ARE USED TO
PROTECT JOBS HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AS FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
I AND I DID MENTION BEFORE THAT
THOSE THAT HAVE. BEEN VOTE IN
THE COMMITTEE HAD NO MY USUAL
PRACTICES UP TO. FOUR USUALLY
EACH SIDE THE COULD HAVE TWO
MINUTES EACH GROUP. EACH WITH
THIS KIND OF UP TO TWO MINUTES
FOUR MINUTES TOTAL IF THEY- SO
CHOOSE. HERNANDEZ WERE VERY GOOD
ONTIME SO WASN'T ISSUE HERE- IF
YOU HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES.
ALL RIGHT WITH. THEM THAT'S- GO
AHEAD TO PUBLIC COMMENT- AND IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM. THE
LIKE TO COMMENT ON AB SIXTY NO
ONE. ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO TO OUR
MODERATOR AND SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN SUPPORT ON THE PHONE.
IF YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT AND SUPPORT IF A. B.
SIXTEEN ALL ONE ME PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. FORTY JOIN THE
QUEUE FOR EITHER A DIFFERENT
BILL OR IN OPPOSITION. YOU MAY
REPEAT ONE THEN ZERO TO REMOVE
YOURSELF. WE DO HAVE SEVERAL
LINES IN Q. ARE YOU READY FOR
THE FIRST LINE MISTER YES. THANK
YOU WE'LL GO TO LINE SEVENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THERE
MY NAME IS TIMOTHY ERIC ON
BOSTON AND I AM A MEMBER OF. THE
W.  LOCAL NINE FIVE SEVEN FIVE.
NINE HERE TO- SUPPORTS AB
SIXTEEN- WHAT. THANK YOU. WE
HAVE LINE EIGHTY EIGHT. HI THIS
IS CHRIS BEAUCHAMP WITH
COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF AMERICA
LOCAL NINETY FIVE ELEVEN IN
SUPPORT OF SIXTEEN OH ONE. THANK
YOU. WHINE EIGHTY THREE. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS YVONNE
NELSON WITH THE TO THE LAKE
DISTRICT NINE AND I'M AS POOR OF
AB SIXTY NO ONE. THANK YOU.
BLIND. ONE THIRTEEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MITCH
SNIDER WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO EXPORT THANK YOU
. LINE NINETY. MY NINETY YEAR
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS. I'M WITH
THE W. WAY LOCAL NINETY FOUR
HUNDRED AND I AM SUPPORT OF AB
SIXTEEN ZERO ONE. THANK YOU. WE
HAVE A LINE ONE TWENTY. HI MY
NAME FOR IT THE RED SCARE WITH
COMMUNICATIONS WORKERS OF
AMERICA LOCAL NINE THOUSAND
THREE AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT AB
SIXTEEN OH ONE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NINE EIGHTY ONE. HI MY NAME
IS ANDREA VALENTINE I'M THE
COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF AMERICA
LOCAL NINE FIVE SEVEN FIVE- TO
THE PORT AB SIXTEEN ZERO ONE.
THANK YOU. WELL I AM AT. HI MY
NAME IS ANTHONY TESTA HONORED-
GW A LOCAL NINETY FIVE TEN OUT
OF ORANGE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE DETECTING A LOT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. BLIND. ONE NINETEEN.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THE NAME IS ROBERT
LONGER WITH YOU HAVE YOU A
DISTRICT NINE A MEMBER OF LOCAL
NINETY FOUR TWENTY ONE AND VICE
PRESIDENT OF SACRAMENTO CENTRAL
LABOR COUNCIL IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB SIXTEEN OH ONE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. KLEIN. SEVENTY EIGHT.
HELLO ONE HELLO MY NAME IS SCOTT
TURNER I AM LEGISLATIVE
POLITICAL CAMPAIGN THE FOR CW A
DISTRICT NINE INDEFINITE STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN OH ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. QUIEN ONE
TWENTY TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON- THIS
IS KELLY MURPHY EXECUTIVE BOARD
MEMBER OF CW A LOCAL NINETY FOUR
HUNDRED AND STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
SIXTY NO ONE. THANK YOU. QUINE
EIGHTY SEVEN. HI MY NAME CANNOT
JOB OF COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF
AMERICA LOCAL NINE THOUSAND
THREE AND I'M A 100% SUPPORT OF
BILL SIXTEEN ALL ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. BLIGNAUT. ONE
SEVENTEEN. ONE SEVENTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MOVEON LINE EIGHTY
FIVE. NINE EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. BOTTOM LINE NINETY
SEVEN. HI HE HI MY NAME IS AJ
THE ONE I'M WITH LOCAL NINETY
FIVE ZERO FIVE AND I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE P. B-
SIXTEEN OH ONE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NINE ONE OH FIVE. HI THIS
IS THE AETNA ROSTER FROM CW A
LOCAL NINETY FOUR TWELVE IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTY NO ONE.
THANK YOU. BLIGNAUT ONE- EVAN.
WHAT ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON. HELLO READY. YOU
WANT TO GO AHEAD AND STATE YOUR
NAME A POSITION PLEASE. LET'S GO
HEAD MOVE ON AND SEE IF- COME
BACK TO THAT PERSON. ONE ONE
TWENTY FIVE. HI MY NAME IS MEGAN
MCCORMICK OF THE PRESIDENCY OF
YOU A LOCAL NINE FIVE EIGHT
EIGHT AND I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB SIXTEEN OH ONE. THANK YOU.
WE HAVE LINE ONE TWENTY THREE. A
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
DOMINIQUE THOMAS OF THIS IS THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF AMERICA
DISTRICT NINE I'M IN SUPPORT OF
AB SIXTEEN ZERO ONE. THANK YOU.
THIS TIME TURNOUT FOR THE LINES
IN Q. FOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I WANT TO THANK
YOU AUTHORS WELL FOR THE
FLEXIBILITY AS WELL AS THE
SPONSOR REPRESENTATIVE IN TERMS
OF THE WITNESS TESTIMONY AND I'M
VERY GRATEFUL FOR THAT- LET'S
SEE NOW IF THERE IS ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION AS ANYONE. OF
TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION. COME
ON UP. I COULDN'T TAKE A SEAT
OVER HERE AND- WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY THANK. A GOOD AFTERNOON
ACTUALLY HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO SB SIXTY NO ONE A
WELL WE CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
INTENSE OF THE BILL TO KEEP JOBS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA OUR CONCERN
ULTIMATELY WITH THIS BILL IN THE
PRIOR BILL IS THAT IT WOULD DO
THE OPPOSITE OF WHAT THE BILL
DOES IS PENALIZED ANY COMPANY
THAT HAS CALL CENTRE OPERATIONS
IN CALIFORNIA THAT DECIDES TO
LATER MOVE THOSE OPERATIONS TO A
DIFFERENT COUNTRY. THE FIRST
REQUIRES BUSINESSES TO PROVIDE A
HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS NOTICE
BEFORE ANY SUCH MOVE AND ANY
EVEN GOOD FAITH MISTAKE OF THAT
WOULD SUBJECT THEM TO PENALTIES
THAT ARE PRETTY STAGGERING OF
TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS PER DAY
PLUS PENALTIES UNDER PAGA. A
SECOND THE BILL WOULD REQUIRE
DIR TO POST THE NAME OF THOSE
COMPANIES ONLINE AND THEN MOST
SIGNIFICANTLY IT WOULD REQUIRE
CALIFORNIA TO DENY THOSE
COMPANIES ANY STATE BENEFITS OR
GRANTS OR TAX CREDITS FOR A FULL
FIVE YEARS I WON COMPANIES ARE
WEIGHING YOU KNOW WHERE TO PLACE
NEW JOBS THESE ARE THE KINDS OF
LAWS THAT WE ARE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT WILL TO TURN THEM FROM
CHOOSING CALIFORNIA AND THAT'S
ESPECIALLY TRUE WHEN YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT JOBS LIKE THOSE
LOCATED IN A CALL CENTER THAT
CAN EASILY BE DONE REMOTELY IN
OTHER STATES- TWO YEAR AT SORRY
THREE YEARS AGO IN TWENTY
NINETEEN GOVERNOR NEWSOM VETO
THIS ALMOST EXACT SAME BILL. AND
HE SAID IN HIS VETO MESSAGE THAT
WHILE HE OF COURSE APPRECIATE
THE INTENT TO PROTECT JOBS HERE
THAT HIS CONCERN AS WELL WAS
THAT THIS WOULD DETER COMPANIES
FROM INVESTING IN CALIFORNIA
WHICH ULTIMATELY HURTS
CALIFORNIA WORKERS SO WE THINK
THAT VETO MESSAGE IS STILL VERY.
TODAY ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF
WHAT FINANCIAL DEVASTATION THE
BUSINESSES HAVE SUFFERED DURING
THE PANDEMIC AND THERE BE EVEN
MORE CHOOSY WHEN THEY'RE REALLY
CHOOSING WHERE TO PUT THEIR JOBS
AND WHERE TO INVEST IN THE
FUTURE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU WE CAN HANG
OUT AND IF YOU LIKE OKAY
SPOKESMEN HAVE QUESTIONS AND IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE HERE IN
OPPOSITION. IN THE ROOM. OKAY
LET'S GO AHEAD OF THE PHONE
LINES ANYONE IN OPPOSITION ON
THE PHONE. THE STATE OPPOSITION
TO AB SIXTEEN OH ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. AGAIN
THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME PLEASE. WE DO HAVE A
FEW LINES WITH OPERATORS WILL BE
JUST A MOMENT SURE.
OUR FIRST COMMENT WILL COME FROM
LINE NINETY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON TURN
MEMBERS BENJAMIN LEE ON BEHALF
OF THE COMPANY TAXPAYERS
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION
WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB
SIXTEEN OH ONE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. WE HAVE LINE ONE TWENTY ONE
. AFTERNOON THIS IS JEANNIE HOW
FROM THE CIVIL JUSTICE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO AB
SIXTEEN OH ONE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ONE ONE TWENTY SEVEN. ONE
TWO SEVEN YOU MIGHT BE ON ME.
OF COURSE OUTLINE AND MOVED ON
BUT AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NO
OTHER LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OF ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM MEMBERS. DECEMBER REYES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I DO WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD- MAYBE IT WAS
VETOED BEFORE BUT TO THIS IS THE
DOING APPROVED. VERSION AND I DO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING UP I
THINK WHAT'S THE IMPORTANT
DISTINCTION IS THAT. IT ISN'T
JUST ANY CALL CENTER TO THOSE
WHO RECEIVE MONEY TAXPAYER MONEY
I THINK THAT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
DISTINCTION THAT IF WE'RE-
GIVING AND LOANING AND GIVING.
ANY KIND OF AID WITH OUR
TAXPAYER MONIES. THEN THE
BUSINESS SHOULD BE KEPT HERE AND
I DO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. AND I
ALSO WANT TO RECOGNIZE FROM MY
COMMUNITY MARTINA ORTEGA I DON'T
KNOW IF SHE WAS ABLE TO CALL IN
FOR MY LOCAL C. W. WEI WHO WAS.
A GREAT PROPONENT PROPONENT OF
THIS BILL AND FAILED TO ADVISE
ME THAT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
WOULD HELP. OUR LOCAL WORKERS-
TO GREAT EXTENT I THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD THINKING
AND WOULD LIKE TO MAKE MOTION
MEADOW MAJORITY LEADER. RIGHT.
DECEMBER JONES SAWYER AND I ALSO
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD- AND I'VE MAYBE ADD
A LITTLE MORE COLOR CONTEXT TO
IT- THEY ALSO MAY HELP YOU WITH
WITH THE GOVERNOR- THE PHARMACY
W. AWAY FROM UNION MEMBER AND A
FORMER EMPLOYEE OF PACIFIC BELL
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE THAT WAS A TIME
WHEN WE HAD. I WORKED IN WHAT
WAS CALLED A PHONE CENTERS STORE
NOT A CELL PHONES IN A STORE.
BUT PHONES THAT YOU PLUG INTO
THE WALL. AND I SO PHONES OUT OF
THEIR. LATER BUT THEY
CONSOLIDATED INTEGRATE
CONSOLIDATION OF ALL THE OF ALL
THE PHONE COMPANIES AND I WORK
FOR EIGHTEEN T. IN A CALL CENTER
WITH FIVE HUNDRED PEOPLE THE
COLOR PRESIDENT EMBEDDED BASED
ORGANIZATION. AND WE TO CALL
STIRS HAVE PEOPLE HOOK UP THEIR
PHONES ALL OVER- SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. I REMEMBER ALMOST ON
AN ANNUAL BASIS OF CORPORATE WE
TALK ABOUT MOVING TO TEXAS
ALABAMA. I DON'T THINK THEY
REALLY UNDERSTOOD THE
DEVASTATING IMPACT IT HAD ON THE
EMPLOYEES. THE EMPLOYEE MORALE
WAS HORRIBLE BECAUSE YOU DIDN'T
KNOW WHETHER OR NOT YOU COULD
PAY YOUR RENT NEXT YEAR BUY A
CAR BUY A HOUSE SEND YOUR KIDS
TO COLLEGE BECAUSE EVERY YEAR
ALMOST EVERY YEAR. AT&T WAS
TALKING ABOUT MOVING FIVE
HUNDRED JOBS OUT OF LOS ANGELES
AT THE TIME PASADENA AND INTO IN
INTO IN INTO TEXAS WAS PROBABLY
WHY I DON'T LIKE TEXAS TO THIS
DAY- BUT IF THEY COULD HAVE.
COULD HAVE JUST SEEN AT THE
BREAK ROOM IN THE LUNCH ROOM AND
AFTERWARDS WHEN PEOPLE GET
TOGETHER- HOW WORRIED THEY WERE
ABOUT THEIR FAMILIES AND THEIR
FUTURES AND JUST TO TALK OF IT.
WAS JUST DEVASTATING- THEY WOULD
UNDERSTAND WHY THERE'S A NEED
FOR THIS LAW- WHY IS A NEED TO
LET PEOPLE KNOW AHEAD OF TIME
WHAT YOU'RE THINKING. BECAUSE
SOMETIMES THEY WOULD JUST COME
IN AND ABRUPTLY. RODDY HERE WHEN
TEXAS YOU GOT. YOU GOT TO MOVE
TO TEXAS. IF WE CAN FIND YOU A
JOB FOR. YOU JUST HAVE A LOOK
AND I DOES FIVE HUNDRED PEOPLE
CAME MY FRIENDS OF MY STILL KNOW
SOMEONE TO THIS DAY- MOST OF
THEM DID NOT RETIRE FROM
EIGHTEEN ANTI BECAUSE THEY DID
MOVE THOSE JOBS OUT OF OUT OF
CALIFORNIA AND SHOW UP MMHM I
KNOW THE DEVASTATING IMPACT.
PERSONAL IMPACT BUT WHEN THAT
HAPPENS AND SO LIGHT I THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD. THANK
YOU A SIMILAR BIGELOW. IF
ANYTHING THAT THAT IS WHERE. I
THE RIFLE I DIDN'T BOTHER. THANK
YOU WE ARE VERY CLOSE I WOULD TO
JOHN WHICH WITH EACH OTHER YOU
KNOW THAT THE STORY KIND OF
LEADS US FROM THE CRANK PHONE
MOMENT ACTUALLY TO THE ROTARY
TYPE PHONE DISCUSSION. WHAT
WE'RE REALLY TALKING ABOUT
TODAY'S PHONE SYSTEMS. AND WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT TECHNOLOGY THAT
DOESN'T EVEN DEAL WITH PHONES
ANYMORE. AND SO THE REAL BIG
ISSUE HERE IS WHILE WE SEE THE
VALUE OF WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH WHICH IS HELPING
CALIFORNIA'S KEEP JOBS HERE AND
RETAIN PEOPLE. THE WAR THE WORLD
HAS CHANGED AND WHAT WE'RE DO
SEEING NOW IS MOST OF THESE CALL
CENTERS ARE NOT IN AMERICA.
THERE IN OTHER COUNTRIES YOU
MIGHT FIND ONE IN TENNESSEE YOU
MIGHT FIND ONE IN LOUISIANA.
MIGHT EVEN FIND ONE A TEXAS
STILL. BUT MOST ALL AROUND THE
COUNTRY EAST INDIA. AND THAT'S
WHERE THEY'RE AT. AND WHEN
THEY'RE LOOKING AT THE DOLLARS
AND CENTS IN THE BOTTOM LINE HOW
TO. GET THINGS DONE. IT'S NOT
GONNA MATTER ABOUT THE GRANTS.
WITH ALL RESPECT TO THIS TO
CALIFORNIA. WE CAN'T KEEP UP WE
CAN'T KEEP OUR UNDERWRITING
THESE. ARE BUSINESSES THAT ARE
MOVING. BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH MONEY TO COMPETE. THEY
ARE MORE PROFITABLE IN ANOTHER
COUNTRY. AND WE ARE USING THOSE
SERVICES EVERY DAY EVERY
BUSINESS IN THE STATE UNLESS
YOU'RE GONNA BAN. INTERNATIONAL
TRADE WHICH THIS BILL WILL
SURELY BE LITIGATED UNDER THE
NAFTA OF LOS. IT'S LIKELY TO NOT
MOVE MUCH FARTHER EVEN IF WE ALL
VOTE ON IT AND SEND IT FORWARD
SO WITH THAT SAID I RESPECT IT
WILL HAVE TO OPPOSE YOUR BILL
TODAY BUT I APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH
HERE- IN TRYING TO HAVE SOME
BUSINESS. BUT WHEN A DIFFERENT
PLAYING FIELD AND WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO REALIZE THAT AND
RECOGNIZED AS WE TRY TO PUSH
BROADBAND AS WE TRY TO DO ALL
THESE OTHER THINGS IT'S ALL TIED
TOGETHER. AND IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
US TO REMEMBER THAT AND
RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU AND HAVE A
CHANCE TO OVERCOME A REPUBLICAN
PLACEMENTS AND I WANT TO WELCOME
BACK IS IN RECOVERY OF- WHO'S
REPLACING- IF THE BILL IN THE
DEMOCRATIC VACANCY TODAY. SUMMER
I THINK YOU HAVE SOME COMMENTS
ON THIS OKAY. ALL RIGHT SO WE DO
HAVE A MOTION I I'D REALLY LIKE
TO BE DOCKED WEBER PUT IT IT'S A
JOB AND TAXPAYER PROTECTION
MEASURE. BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE IT
IS A VERY WE'RE GETTING TAX OUR
MONEY THERE SHOULD BE SOME
EXPECTATION. THAT ARE ACTUALLY
JOBS CREATED WITH I THINK I
THINK OUR- RESIDENTS WOULD
EXPECT THAT AND SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE HIS BILL- AND LUDBEY
JINED TWENTY AS A CO AUTHOR AT
THE- AS WELL. I WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE YES. THANK YOU. I'M FIRST
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
FOR ALLOWING THIS BILL TO BE
HEARD TODAY I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK ALL OF THOSE WHO- HAVE
VOICED THEIR SUPPORT AND ALSO
FOR THOSE WHO'VE COME TO ENGAGE
IN THE DISCUSSION OPPOSITION-
YOU KNOW MY FELLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS- AND I WANT TO MAKE
CLEAR THAT WE'RE NOT. TELLING
COMPANIES THAT THEY CANNOT GO
SOMEWHERE ELSE. WE'RE JUST
SAYING THAT IF YOU GO YOU JUST
CAN'T REAP THE BENEFIT OF ANY
TAX INCENTIVES OR ANY SUBSIDIES
FROM CALIFORNIA. SO IF YOU FEEL
LIKE YOU WOULD WANT TO HAVE A
CALL CENTER IN INDIA HAVE A CALL
CENTER IN INDIA BUT DON'T EXPECT
FOR THE TAXPAYERS IN CALIFORNIA
IS. TO GIVE YOU ANY BREAKS- AND
AS FAR AS PAGLA IS CONCERNED-
YOU KNOW PACK ONLY BECOMES
RELEVANT TO FILL THE GAP AND
LABOR CODE CODE ENFORCEMENT. M.
IF THE STATE IS UNABLE OR
UNWILLING TO ACT TO STEP IN AND
SO. AND YOU KNOW WHAT EVERYONE
SHOULD KNOW IF YOU'RE GONNA USE
PACKET THAT- HAS VERY STRICT
REQUIREMENTS SO IN ORDER TO
BRING ABOUT A PACK A CLAIM THE
EMPLOYEE MATH. MEETS THE FORMAL
NOTICE AND WAITING PERIOD
REQUIREMENTS UNDER THE LABOR
CODE SECTION TWENTY SIX. NINETY
EIGHT THE EMPLOYEE MUST ADMIT AB
PACKET CLAIM NOTICE TO THE
LABOR. AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY AND GIVE THE AGENCY TIME
TO REVIEW AND NOTICE AND DECIDE
WHETHER OR NOT AND WHICH IS TO
INVESTIGATE THE CLAIM. IF AND
ONLY IF THE L. W. D. H. CHOOSES
NOT TO INVESTIGATE- OR IT DOES
NOT OTHERWISE RESPOND TO THE
CLAIM THAT A SPECIFIED TIME.
THEN YOU'RE ENTITLED TO BRING A
PAGA CLAIM AND SO THIS WOULD
UNLIKELY. RESULT IN AN INCREASE
IN AND PACKET CLASS AIMS. AND TO
THE- THAT GOVERNOR HAD VETOED
BEFORE- THAT WAS AT THE TIME. AS
WITH STATUS. AND I'M A PHYSICIAN
I BELIEVE AN EVIDENCE BASED ON
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE DIDN'T
HAVE THEM THAT WE DO HAVE NOW.
IS EVIDENCE THAT THESE LAWS WORK
AS WAS STATED. BY MISTER
HERNANDEZ. AYE WHAT HAS BEEN
DONE IN NEW YORK WHICH IS
STRICTER THAN WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO NOW. HAS ACTUALLY SHOWN IS
TIED INTO UPTICK IN JOBS NOT A
LOS ANGELES TIMES- SO I JUST
WANTED TO DEFINITELY ADDRESS
THOSE POINTS- ANY CONCLUSION I
WANT TO STATE THAT CORPORATE TAX
INCENTIVES AND SUBSIDIES. SHOULD
BE BASED IN THE STATE WHERE THE
JOBS ARE. I. E. WHERE THE
TAXPAYERS ARE LOCATED.
CONTINUING TO SUBSIDIZE
CORPORATIONS THAT EXPORT CALL
CENTER JOBS. IT'S A DISSERVICE
TO THE RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA
AND ONLY SERVES TO INCENTIVIZE
THIS BEHAVIOR FROM CORPORATIONS.
THIS BILL WILL SUPPORT OUR CALL
CENTER WORKERS RETAIN JOBS IN
CALIFORNIA AND PRIVATE EYES ARE
SCARCE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
RESOURCES. TO COMPANIES
INVESTING LOCALLY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
ABOUT. SOMEONE THAT IS TAKEN ON
NOT MORE THAN ONE OCCASION AND
FORMALLY VETOED BILL THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COURAGE AND YOUR AND
YOUR AND YOUR WORKS I DON'T TAKE
A LOT OF WORK. TO WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND HOW A SOCIAL
PASS OFFICIATED. WE DO HAVE A
MOTION OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS TO
PASS TO APPROACH. WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM A CINEMA REYES
SECOND BY SOME MEMBERS JONES
SAWYER MADAM SECRETARY. TAKE
WILL ON THE VOTE. MOTION IS DUE
PASSED APPROPRIATE. KALRA HI
KALRA HI BIGELOW. BIGELOW NO
JONES SAWYER HI JONES SAWYER AYE
REYES REYES I'D CHEN. CHEN KNOWN
WARD BY WARD HI CARILLO CARILLO
HI THERE THE BILL'S OUT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. FILE ITEM TO AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTEEN SUMMARIZE
YOUR CURRY IS HERE READY TO GO.
ALL RIGHT WHENEVER WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY YOU MAY PERCEIVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL MAKE
IT QUICK GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BEFORE I BEGIN
I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFFER YOU WORK ON
THE ANALYSIS OF THIS BILL. TRULY
APPRECIATED. AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTEEN EXPANDS THE DEFINITION
OF PUBLIC WORKS TO INCLUDE FUEL
REDUCTION ACTIVITIES PERFORMED
AS PART OF A WILDFIRE MITIGATION
PROJECT THIS WILL BETTER PROTECT
COMMUNITIES FROM WILDFIRES BY
ENSURING THAT WORKERS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THESE PROJECTS
ARE WELL TRAINED. USING THE
SAFEST PRACTICES AND PAID
PREVAILING WAGE. YOU KNOW WE
HAVE ALL SEEN THE DEVASTATING
IMPACT OF WILDFIRES IN
CALIFORNIA. IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
ALONE THE STATE SAW CLOSE TO
NINE THOUSAND ACTIVE WILDFIRES
THAT BURNED MORE THAN TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION ACRES OF LAND. AND
SADLY COSTS THREE CALIFORNIANS
THEIR LIVES. GIVEN THIS NEW
REALITY THE STATE HAS POSTED
STRONG STRONG EMPHASIS ON
WILDFIRE IN MITIGATION EFFORTS.
THIS WORK TYPICALLY TYPICALLY
INCLUDES RESIDENTIAL CHIPPING
RURAL ROAD FUEL BREAKS
FIREBREAKS AND VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT WHILE FOR MITIGATION
ACTIVITIES ARE CRUCIAL TO
PROTECTING OUR COMMUNITIES FROM
THE SPREAD OF DANGEROUS FIRES.
WE ALREADY RELY ON FIRE
MITIGATION FOR PUBLIC WORKS
PROJECTS RANGE RANGING FROM
PROTECTING TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE TO DEFENDING
PUBLIC SCHOOLS AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTEEN MAKES CLEAR THAT LOCAL
WORKERS PERFORMING HAZARDOUS
LABOR INTENSIVE WORK DESERVED TO
BE PROPERLY PREPARED FOR THE
JOBS AND PAID A LIVABLE WAGE FOR
THEIR DUTIES. WE HAVE STRONG
SUPPORT FROM SEVERAL LABOR AND
TRADE ORGANIZATIONS THAT KNOW
THE VALUE AND IMPORTANCE A
PREVAILING WAGE TO SUPPORT BOTH
THE WORKERS DOING THIS WORK AND
THE COMMUNITIES THEY PROTECT.
PASSING A B. SEVENTEEN SEVENTEEN
WILLSHOW CALIFORNIA'S
COMMITMENT TO ADDRESSING CLIMATE
CHANGE WHILE ENSURING OUR
WORKERS ARE WELL TREAT HIM
FAIRLY PAID- THREE TODAY TO
TESTIFY SUPPORT TIM CRIMMINS FOR
THE NEVADA CALIFORNIA CONFERENCE
OF OPERATING ENGINEERS. AND JOE
CRUZ FROM THE LABORERS
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF NORTH
AMERICA THANK YOU GENTLEMEN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- AND AS
MENTIONED FOR EACH WITNESSES UP
TO TWO MINUTES SECONDS. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF TIM CRAM
INTERNATIONAL OPERATING YEARS I
THINK I'LL DISPENSE WITH READING
WITH READING COMMENT TO MAYBE A
COUPLE QUICK POINTS- PERSONAL
THIS BILL IS VERY CONSISTENT
WITH PUBLIC POLICY YOU'VE- WE'VE
HAD FOR YEARS- PAYMENT WORKERS.
AREN'T PUBLIC WORKS PROJECTS ON
PUBLIC ASSETS WITH PUBLIC FUNDS
REQUIRES A PAYMENT OF PREVAILING
WAGE THIS IS IN A FAR STEP FROM
THAT AT ALL. A NUMBER TWO- THESE
WORK ZONES ARE TALKING ABOUT ART
V. CONSISTENTLY THE MOST
HAZARDOUS OF A VERY DISTANT
BASIS IF YOU LOOK THAT UP YOU'LL
SEE THAT. A PREVAILING WAGE
WITH- WITH THE PARTNERSHIP
TRAINING WILL REDUCE THOSE
ACCENTS ON THOSE VERY- HAZARDS
PROJECTS- BUT ALSO OF REMINDS
YOU CURRENTLY NOW UNDER STATUTE
REQUIRING PAYMENT OF PREVAILING
WAGE HOW. IS THIS REQUIRED FOR
TREE REMOVAL OF THE HAULING AND
DISPOSAL OF MATERIAL AND
LANDSCAPE MANAGEMENT THAT IS
REQUIRED PREVAILING WAGE NOW AND
VERY SIMILAR TO FIRE MITIGATION
WORK- AND I'D SAY THE SKILL
SETS. THAT THIRTY BEING USED NOW
CLOSELY MONITOR ALL THOSE
REQUESTS UNDER PREVAILING WAGE-
ALSO IT SHOULD BE NOTED TO THAT.
OF VOLUNTEER WORK WORK DONE BY
CONSERVATION CORPS DOES NOT
REQUIRE THE PAYMENT OF
PREVAILING WAGE IN THIS BILL
THAT'S NOT PAID- CHANGE THAT AT
ALL THAT COULD STILL BE
CONTINUED UNDER THIS BILL- ALSO
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF TALK. IN
YOU'LL SEE A OF ADOPTING OUR
STATE WORKFORCE TO CLIMATE
CHANGE BUT WE THINK THIS HELPS
THAT. IN THAT YOU'LL YOU'LL HAVE
MEMBERS LIVING IN RURAL AREAS
TRAVELING TO URBAN AREAS TO
WORK. WITH THE EXACT SAME SKILLS
THAT THEY CAN BE USING RIGHT IN
THEIR COMMUNITY PERFORMED AT IF
YOU'VE GOT COMMON BENEFITS
COMMON WAGE RATES THEY CAN STAY
HOME AND PERFORM THAT WORK ON
CLIMATE CHANGE PROJECTS- AND
AGAIN I THINK A LEAD CLICK.
AGENTS HE- WE SAY A PROVIDES ON
THE PROJECTS- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU UNSCR MISTER THIS
COULD BE BACK IN A COUPLE YEARS
SINCE I'VE BEEN IN THIS. THE
EVERYBODY'S FACE- FIRST I WANT
TO THANK OF THE AUTHOR WHO'S
BEEN EXCEPTIONALLY. A CHAMPION
ON THIS ISSUE- NOT JUST FOR
WILDFIRE MITIGATION BUT FOR
WORKING PEOPLE INTO SURE THEY'RE
SAFE- ON THESE VERY DANGEROUS
JOBS- IF YOU LOOK AT THE BUREAU
OF LABOR STATISTICS- THE MEN AND
WOMEN WHO ARE TREE WORKERS. THEY
CAN EXPERIENCE FIFTEEN TIMES
HIGHER. FATALITY RATE. THEY'RE
THREE TIMES MORE LIKELY TO BE
INJURED. IN THESE OCCUPATIONS
FROM WORKING IN THESE VERY
DANGEROUS AREAS. OF SO. PART OF
THAT PREVAILING WAGE IS OUR
RIGOROUS FURNITURE PROGRAM AND
BEFORE YOU PICK UP ONE TOOL. YOU
ARE TAKING CPR FIRST AID OSHA
SAFETY AND HAZARDOUS WASTE
MATERIAL- HANDLING SO YOU GO
INTO THOSE- THOSE JOBS ALREADY
PREPARED- UNFORTUNATE FOR THE
WORST CASE SCENARIO SOMETIMES-
SO WE'RE REALLY. PROUD OF OUR
PROGRAMS. I THINK- MISTER
CRIMSON THIS MADE A GOOD COMMENT
ABOUT WE TALK ABOUT THE
OPPORTUNITIES TO CREATE REALLY
GOOD MIDDLE CLASS JOBS AGREED
ECONOMY. AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTEEN
IS ONE OF THOSE THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE GOOD
PAYING JOBS IN THE AREAS OF THE
STATE OF. FAR REACHING AREAS.
FOR TRAVELING EVERY SINGLE DAY
TO A AS A MEMBER KALRA DISTRICT.
UP FOR WORK- THIS WILL ALLOW
THOSE FOLKS TO STAY HOME. TO
WORK AND CREATE A ANOTHER
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY LIKE WE
REALLY NEVER SEEN BEFORE IN THIS
INDUSTRY- SO WITH THAT I- I ASK
YOU TO CONSIDER THIS IT'S A
GREAT BILL IT'S A IT'S A MOVE IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION. AND WE
SIMPLY REPEAT YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR A BI SEVEN
SEVENTEEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN FIRST TODD BLOOM STEIN
FOR THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. I CAN BE
ACTUALLY ONE OF THIS AND WE CAN
GET THAT WHEN THE WHEN THE
MICROPHONE SET UP. THE FOR-
AUDIENCE TESTIMONY. IT MIGHT BE
EASIER THAN HAVING TO ALWAYS
COME ALL THE WAY UP AND BACK AND
FORTH. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MIKE
WEST ON BEHALF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. MUCH MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MAP BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT LET'S GO
AHEAD TO THE PHONE LINES
MODERATOR WAS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTEEN. IF YOU WISH TO
EXPRESS YOUR SUPPORT AND HAVE
NOT ALREADY DONE SO PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. AGAIN THAT'S
ONE NUMBER ZERO. HELLO FIRST OF
LINE OF ONE OH THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE IS DISCONNECTED WILL
GO TO ONE THIRTY FOUR. A GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR WHICH IS
MARK SPENCER MAKER ON BEHALF OF
THE WATERSHED RESEARCH AND
TRAINING CENTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK THE MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD THANKS VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. ONE LINE ONE THIRTY
FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS. GOVERNMENT GO AHEAD.
THE MOMENT I AM PLEASED THAT BUT
MINE IS ALSO DISCONNECTED. WE'LL
GO TO LINE ONE THIRTY THREE AND
I'LL CHECK ON ONE THIRTY FIVE
ONE THIRTY THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN KALRA AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THIS IS KIND OF
WALKING CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS. AS WELL AS
THE COALITION OF CALIFORNIA
UTILITY EMPLOYEES. REGISTER OUR
STRONG SUPPORT ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
SEVEN ONE SEVEN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU. THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME THEY'RE NOT FOR THE
ALLIANCE IN QUEUE FOR SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS THERE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION. THERE'S NO
I DON'T WE DON'T HAVE ANY-
WITNESSED A- WITNESS MAIN
PRIMARY WITNESS S. MAIN
OPPOSITION. YEAH SO BUT SO IS
ONE OF THE ROOM NOT POSITION
THIS IS GO TO THE PHONES EVEN
WAS ON THE CALL IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU CORRECTEXPRESS
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL YOU MAY
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO USING
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. THANK AND
THAT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ALTHOUGH FIRST ALIGNED WON ALL
THREE. TIELINE ONE OH THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
AFFECT ME YES YES OKAY HELLO I
DIDN'T GET A LINE NUMBER HI
STACEY HEATING ROHTANG
REPRESENTATIVE CALIFORNIA HAS
BEEN TALKING TO THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE ABOUT THE PHONE ALREADY
WERE RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION
HOPING WE CAN WORK OUT SOME
AMENDMENTS FOR THE VITAL PUBLIC
SAFETY ISSUE THAT IS GOING TO
IMPACT A LOT OF OUR COUNTY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ONE AND ONE
THIRTY SEVEN. JUST A MOMENT
PROVIDE ONE THIRTY SEVEN. BY ONE
THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CHRIS ROSA ON BEHALF OF KELP
FORESTS THIS IS THE SITUATION OF
LOVE THE AUTHOR BUT- OPPOSING
THE BILL WE'D LIKE TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR AMBER STAFF
FOR THEIR ACCESSIBILITY AND
WILLINGNESS TO MEET EARLY ON
EVEN THOUGH WE DON'T SEE EYE TO
OUR INABILITY TO LOOK CLOSER TO
WORK WITH YOU AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO FURTHER DISCUSSION.
THANK YOU. WHAT'S GOING TO BE
LOVED YES BUT- FOR. ANYONE ELSE
ON THE LINE AS MODERATOR. NO FOR
THE LINES IN Q. THANK YOU WE DO
HAVE A MOTION ANY COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS. THE SERVER CHEN. IT IS
ONE OF A GATHERING THIS BILL
ABOARD YOU DON'T HAVE THE
PLEASURE- THE PAST PROBABLY
RETURN AFTER YEARS OF VISITING
MY LOCAL TRADES IN L. A. COUNTY
ORANGE COUNTY AND FOR ME
PERSONALLY WAS I OPEN EXPERIENCE
EXPERIENCE WHICH I DO HAVE THE
FORTUNATE PRODUCERS PASSED THE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS THAT YOU
HAVE FOR THE TRADES ARE
INCREDIBLE AND THEY OFTEN SAY
THAT NOT EVERYONE IS MEANT TO GO
TO A FOUR YEAR COLLEGE THE
TREATY TOLD. PROGRAMS IS A
COLLEGE COURSE NOT ONLY TO GET
HANDS ON EXPERIENCE BUT ALSO TO
GET TECHNICAL TRAINING AS WELL
AS THEORETICAL TRAINING AND IT
TAKES YEARS FOR THEM TO GET
LICENSED AND CERTIFICATED AND-
THEY TOLD ME THAT IT'S IMPORTANT
TO BE ABLE TO MEASURE TWICE AND
CUT ONCE AND ALSO INCREASE THE
LIKELIHOOD OF LIABILITY
LITIGATION FOR MY FRIENDS AND
DEVELOPMENT COMMUNITY SO I THINK
THAT'S REALLY CRITICAL. HERE IN
OUR STATE IN CALIFORNIA. I KNOW
SAY THAT- ISSUES SUCH AS
COMMITTEE WHERE AGREEMENTS HAS
THE OPPORTUNITY. FOR INDIVIDUALS
AND TRADE ORGANIZATIONS TO WORK
WHERE THEY LIVE IN THE
COMMUNITY. I THINK ESPECIALLY
FOR NOW. THAT GAS PRICES AS MUCH
AS YOU KNOW TEN DOLLARS A GALLON
SO. I THINK THIS IS A GOOD
BALANCE BEFORE SUPPORTING IT
THANKS FOR BRINGING MORE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU A
SUMMER VEHICLE- THANK YOU  KNOW
YOU HAD ONE COLOR IN THERE THAT
TALK ABOUT WORKING WITH YOU I
WANT TO CONTINUE TO TRY TO GET
SOME MOVEMENT ON THAT- I I'M
HOPEFUL THAT THAT CAN HAPPEN
BECAUSE I THINK THE REALITY IS
THERE ARE SOME SMALL COUNTIES
THAT ARE GOING TO BE IMPACTED BY
THIS THAT MAYBE YOU CAN FIND
SOME MOVEMENT IN AND IN AND WITH
THAT SAID- I'LL HOLD UP ON MY
VOTE TODAY YOU KNOW ON IT
BECAUSE I'M GONNA SEE IT AGAIN.
HE WILL. I KNOW. AND SO ANYWAY
AND GIVE YOU TIME TO MAYBE
ACTORS LIKE THAT WITHOUT HAVING.
A NEGATIVE VOTE PUT UP ON IT SO
I'D LIKE TO SEE THAT. BECAUSE I
THINK THAT THERE'S SOME
ACHIEVABLE GROUND HERE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
SUMMARY IS. AS WITH MY COMMENT
WITH THE PRIOR A PRESENTER WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT PUBLIC WORKS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT PUBLIC FUNDING AS
MR CRIMMINS TALKED ABOUT- WE'RE
IF WE VALUE THOSE WHO ARE DOING
THIS WORK TO HELP THE REST OF
SOCIETY WE HAVE TO PROVIDE THEM
WITH LIVABLE WAGES AND I THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WELL THE IT THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR OU KNOW AND WE KEEP
TALKING ABOUT INFRASTRUCTURE
FUNDS IN PUBLIC RIGHT I DON'T
THINK I CAN'T THINK OF ANY MORE
IMPORTANT PUBLIC WORKS. A
PRIORITIES- THAN WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE BOB MYERS AND
IT'S GOT TO BE DONE RIGHT THE
FIRST TIME. THAT YOU WANT DONE
RIGHT THE FIRST TIME YOU NEED
TRAINED SKILLED WORKERS GETTING
PAID PREVAILING WAGE AND I THINK
THIS IS A WIN WIN. ALL AROUND
AND SO I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OFFER BRING THIS FORWARD I WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE. HER REAL QUICK
LIKE YOU KNOW WE HAVE TO
REMEMBER FORCE WORK IS
CONSISTENTLY LISTED AS THE MOST
DANGEROUS JOB IN THE NATION. AND
DESIGNATED MITIGATION WORK AS A
PUBLIC WORKS ENSURES THAT
JOURNEYMEN APPRENTICES WHO HAVE
BEEN THROUGH EXTENSIVE SAFETY
TRAINING WILL BE BE BE
PERFORMING THIS WORK AS WELL AS
GETTING A LIVING WAGE A
PREVAILING WAGE. SO I WANT TO
THANK YOU ALL AND I ASK YOU FOR
YOUR RIVAL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE HAVE A MOTION FROM CINEMA
REYES SECOND BY SUNOCO DEAL. UP
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS BENHAM
SECRETARY. CRITICAL ROLE IN THE
BOOK PLEASE. MOCEANU TO PASS TWO
PROBES KALRA I KALRA HI BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING JONES SAWYER
BY JONES SAWYER AYE REYES. REYES
AYE CHAN. CHAN I WARD. WARD I'D
CARRILLO. CARILLO I. SAID BILLS
ON THE WAY TO APPROACH THAT YOU
VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT UP NEXT.
YEAH BUT DR ROBERT I DID SEE ON
HERE AND HE'S MAKING HIS WAY UP
AS THE OTHER GROUP LEAVES THE
ROOM WE'LL HAVE ITEM THREE. A.
B. EIGHTEEN TWENTY. AND-
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. DR ON THE
- WE HAVE A MOTION TEN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL FROM DECEMBER
CARILLO. IS THERE A SECOND.
SECOND INCINERATORS SO YOU'RE
OFF TO A GOOD START DR. I WILL
KEEP MY COMMENTS SHORT. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I WOULD
FIRST LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALL THE HARD WORK
ON THE BILL AND THE RECOMMENDED
IMPROVEMENTS I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT AMENDMENTS AS WE HAVE
DISCUSSED. AB EIGHTEEN TWENTY IT
WILL PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S MOST
VULNERABLE WORKERS FROM BEING
TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF BY
INDIVIDUALS WHO WILL FORCE THEM
TO WORK UNDER DURESS WITH LITTLE
OR NO PAY AT ALL. THERE ARE MANY
DIFFERENT SITUATIONS WHERE
TRAFFICKED WORKERS FACE SUCH AS
THREATS FROM EMPLOYERS WHO ARE
RELATING OR REACTING. TO ME SUCH
AS THREATS FROM EMPLOYERS
RELATING TO THEIR OWN
DOCUMENTATION STATUS FROM THE
WITHHOLDING OF THEIR WAGES AND
FROM THE THREATS AND SAFETY OF
THEIR OWN FAMILY. ALL OF THESE
INTIMIDATION TACTICS CAN PREVENT
VICTIMS FROM REPORTING THEIR
TRAFFICKERS. WHILE THERE ARE
DEPARTMENTS WHICH PROSECUTES
TRAFFICKING CRIMES THERE IS NO
STATE AGENCIES THAT HAS A
MANDATE TO LOOK FOR LABOR
TRAFFICKING. AB EIGHTEEN TWENTY
WILL CREATE A LABOR TRAFFICKING
UNIT WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS A
DEPARTMENT WHICH IS ALREADY
TASKED WITH ADMINISTERING AND
ENFORCING LAWS GOVERNING
WORKERS. THIS LABOR TRAFFICKING
UNITS WILL NOT ONLY INVESTIGATE
CASES OF LABOR TRAFFICKING AND
COORDINATE WITH ENTITIES WHICH
ARE INVOLVED IN THIS CASE BUT IT
WILL ALSO SERVE AS A POINT OF
CONTACT FOR THE VICTIMS OF THIS
ABUSE. AB EIGHTEEN TWENTY WILL
ALLOW CALIFORNIA TO PROTECT ITS
WORKERS BY STOPPING TRAFFICKING
BEFORE IT STARTS MMHM. TODAY I
HAVE THE PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE A
FORMER MEMBER OF OUR ASSEMBLY
WHO IS NOW A COMMISSIONER WITH
THE LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION IN
DION ERIN- AND CHRISTOFERSON
CHESS FROM WESTERN CENTER OF
LONG POVERTY. COMMISSIONER
COMMISSIONER ERIN- YES THANK YOU
SO MUCH MET COMMISSIONER PLEASE
THANK YOU SO MUCH OF THANK YOU
DR- HAS SAID MY NAME IS DIONNE
ERIN- AND I'M A MEMBER OF THE
LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION-
APPOINTED ACTUALLY BY THE PRO
TEM. AND I'M HERE TODAY I WANTED
TO SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMISSION AB EIGHTEEN TWENTY.
THE COMMISSION FOR THOSE OF YOU
THAT MIGHT NOT BE FAMILIAR WITH
IT IS AN INDEPENDENT BIPARTISAN
OVERSIGHT AGENCY CHARGED WITH
MAKING RECOMMENDATIONS TO
IMPROVE THE EFFICIENCY AND
EFFECTIVENESS OF STATE
GOVERNMENT. IN TWENTY TWENTY WE
ISSUEDA SERIES OF THREE REPORTS
EXAMINING THE STATE'S RESPONSE
TO LABOR TRAFFICKING. HORRIFIC
FORM OF MODERN SLAVERY. THAT
EXPLOITS INNOCENT WORKERS
THROUGH FORCE FRAUD OR COERCION
. OUR DECISION TO FOCUS ON LABOR
TRAFFICKING STEM FROM THE FACT
THAT EXISTING EFFORTS TO COMBAT
HUMAN TRAFFICKING PRIMARILY
FOCUSED ON SEX TRAFFICKING
THOUGH MANY EXPERTS SUGGEST THAT
LABOR TRAFFICKING IS MUCH MORE
PROPELLANT PREVALENT.
TRAFFICKERS PREY ON THE MOST AS
DOES THE ASSEMBLYMAN SAID PREY
ON THE MOST VULNERABLE AMOUNT
AMONG US REGARDLESS OF AGE
GENDER OR CITIZENSHIP STATUS.
EACH YEAR HUNDREDS OF NON LABOR
TRAFFICKING SURVIVORS TO SEEK
HELP HERE IN CALIFORNIA. YET IN
OUR REPORT ENTITLED LABOR
TRAFFICKING STRATEGIES TO HELP
VICTIMS AND BRING TRAFFICKERS TO
JUSTICE THE COMMISSION FOUND
THAT NO STATE AGENCY CURRENTLY
HAS A MANDATE TO LOOK FOR LABOR
TRAFFICKING. AS A RESULT CASES
BRING TRAFFICKERS TO JUSTICE
CASES BRINGING TRAFFICKERS TO
JUSTICE REMAIN VERY RARE. ON
AVERAGE THERE ARE LESS THAN
THIRTY CONVICTIONS FOR LABOR
TRAFFICKING IN CALIFORNIA EACH
YEAR. ONLY AN AGGRESSIVE
RESPONSE FROM THE HIGHEST LEVELS
OF STATE GOVERNMENT CAN CHANGE
THIS. IN OUR REPORT WE FOUND
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS IS
PARTICULARLY WELL POSITIONED TO
SERVE AT THE FOREFRONT OF
COMBATTED LABOR TRAFFICKING
CRIMES GET IT CURRENTLY LACKS
THE MANDATE TO DO SO. TO ENHANCE
EFFORTS TO BRING LABOR
TRAFFICKERS TO JUSTICE THE
COMMISSION RECOMMENDS THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIFICALLY MANDATE
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS PURSUES
LABOR TRAFFICKING ALONGSIDE ITS
OTHER WORK. TO COMBAT THE
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY. AB EIGHTEEN
TWENTY WOULD ADVANCE THE
COMMISSION'S RECOMMENDATION BY
ESTABLISHING A LABOR TRAFFICKING
UNIT WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT TO
COMBAT THIS HEINOUS CRIME. I
WANT TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON
THIS CRUCIAL ISSUE AND FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL TODAY. ON BEHALF OF
THE LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. ONE RESEARCHER GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
COST RESPONSES POLICY ADVOCATE
WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY PRADA VEHICLE
SPONSOR OF AB EIGHTEEN TWENTY TO
FURTHER COMBAT LABOR TRAFFICKING
IN CALIFORNIA. SOME OF YOU MAY
KNOW THE ROOT CAUSE OF LABOR
TRAFFICKING IS POVERTY. NUMEROUS
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THE
CORRELATION BETWEEN INDIVIDUALS
AND FAMILIES WHO ARE IN EXTREME
POVERTY. AND THEIR VULNERABILITY
TO LABOR TRAFFICKING ESPECIALLY
THOSE WHO ARE WORKING IN LOW
WAGE SECTORS. AND THOSE WHO ARE
IMMIGRANTS WITHOUT LEGAL
PROTECTION UNLIMITED LEGAL
PROTECTIONS I DON'T HAVE ACCESS
TO CRITICAL SOCIAL SERVICES. ARE
EVEN MORE VULNERABLE. OFTENTIMES
LABOR TRAFFICKERS ARE EXPLOITING
THOSE WORKERS WERE THEY HAVE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH OUR REPORT.
WITH WORKERS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
AND THEIR L. WHO AND OFTENTIMES
THERE OTHER OTHER EMPLOYER OTHER
SUPERVISORS. ARE WEST PROVIDE
UNAUTHORIZED LOANS- AND
FINANCIAL. COMPENSATION TO THEM-
THAT IS I'M JUST PROUD TO
WORKERS AND HAS PUT HIM FURTHER
INTO DEBT- WE SEE THIS
ESPECIALLY HAPPENING IN TIMES OF
TRAGEDY AND SHOCK. WHEN IT
HAPPENS IN THE WORKERS LIVE. IN
OTHER INSTANCES INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE LURED INTO TRAFFICKING HAVE
BEEN PROMISED THE MOMENT
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS. JOB
TRAINING ARE SECURING OF AFFECTS
EXCEPT FOR JOBS IN THE UNITED
STATES UNFORTUNATELY. SOME
INDIVIDUALS TAKE THESE PROMISES
OF THE FACE VALUE OF FALLEN TO
THE FORCED LABOR IN HOPES OF.
MOVING THEMSELVES. AND THEIR
FAMILY OUT OF POVERTY. THAT'S
WHY AB TWO TWENTY IS A CRITICAL
INSURE CAL BILL THIS GUY. TO
COMBAT IN THE RETURN IN THE AND
TO ENSURE THAT WORKERS ARE NO
LONGER EXPLODED IN THE STATE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
VERSION WE RECORD DRIVE A- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. BUT IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE ROOM THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF AB
EIGHTEEN TWENTY. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JOSEPH
JELLO WITH A NEW H. INITIATIVE
EARLY ON LAW SCHOOL SEEKING TO
PREVENT HUMAN TRAFFICKING IN
STRONG SUPPORT IT PROGRESS
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN THE
ROOM. IF NOT THEN WE'LL GO AHEAD
TO THE PHONES MISTER MODERATOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE TO SUPPORT
OF AB EIGHTEEN TWENTY. IF YOU TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR A BI
EIGHTEEN TWENTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE.
AGAIN THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO PLEASE. WE'LL GO FIRST TO
LINE ONE FORTY ONE NO LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
REBECCA GONZALEZ FOR THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN TWENTY.
THANK YOU WE HAVE ONE LINE ONE
OH SEVEN. ONE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE BUILDINGS ARE. OVER
AGAIN ALMOST ONLINE ONE FORTY
FOUR. THIS IS MOLLY SHEEHAN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC
CONFERENCE GRATEFUL FOR THIS
BILL AND IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. LINE ONE TWENTY
EIGHT. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THIS IS JOHNNY PINERA ON BEHALF
OF THE QUALIFICATION FOR HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS CHIRLA IN
SUPPORT OF AB. ONE EIGHT TWO
ZERO THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WITHOUT TURN OVER THE LINE THANK
YOU FOR SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH IS ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
THIS MODERATOR IF WANT TO GO TO
THE PHONE TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE CALLING IN IN OPPOSITION
. IF YOU'RE INTERESTED
OPPOSITION TO AB EIGHTEEN TWENTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. AGAIN THAT COMMANDOS ONE
AND THEN ZERO USE YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. HAVING ALLOWED A MOMENT
THERE ARE CURRENTLY NO LINES IN
Q. NO ONE DARE OPPOSE THE GOOD
DOCTOR. BUT ANY ANY COMMENTS OF
YOU ALREADY HAVE A MOTION HE
COMMENTS THIS IS A MEMBER AWARD
CREATE ONE THANK THE AUTHOR- AND
THE SPONSORS FOR RAIN FOR THIS
BILL I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE ARE WORKING ON
LABOR TRAFFICKING ISSUES AS
PERVASIVE AS THEY ARE IN AS
UNDERGROUND AS THEY ARE- IT'S
IMPORTANT WE HAVE ALL RESOURCES
AVAILABLE IN OUR DISPENSED- ALL
EYES AND EARS ON THE GROUND TO
BE ABLE TO LOOK FOR THE SIGNS UP
TO THAT POINT- AND THANK YOU
FOR- YOU KNOW COLLEGE BEING
THROUGH THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS THAT. IT'S IMPORTANT
WE DIRECT THE- PROSECUTORIAL
ACTIVITY TO THOSE WITH THE
AUTHORITY TO DO THAT- FOR THIS
BILL TO- IT RECEIVE INVESTIGATE
AND PROSECUTE COMPLAINTS AND
THAT'S- THAT'S GREAT THAT WE'RE
GIVEN THE AUTHORITY TO DO THAT-
WOULD. ALSO ALLOW CAL OSHA THE
ABILITY OF THEIR ON SITE FOR.
RUN OUT ROUTINE INSPECTIONS OR
FOR OTHER- COMPLAINTS RECTIFY
THESE IF THEY ARE. ABLE TO
OBSERVE- POTENTIAL- EVIDENCE-
OBSERVATIONS THAT THAT LABOR
TRAFFICKING MIGHT BE PRACTICES
THEN AUTHORIZED THEM TO
INITIATE. SOME OF THAT
INVESTIGATION. I WILL LET.
COMMISSIONER IN- SPEAK BUT I
WANTED TO CLARIFY THAT WE ARE
NOT- WE ARE NOT- ALLOWING.
PROSECUTE PROSECUTION WITH THIS
BILL IT'S ONLY INVESTORS RIGHT
RIVER FOR THAT PROPERTY YUXIN IS
GEARED TO REMAIN BOTH WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AS WELL
AS- THE DEPARTMENT OF FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING. RIGHT
AND IF IT'S ACTUALLY BUT BUT
BEFORE WE GO TO THE COMMISSION
ONE ONE TWO ONE CLARIFICATION-
THAT. WE ACTUALLY THE COMMITTEE
DID NOT ACTUALLY ASK. FOR THE
ACCEPTANCE AMENDMENTS BUT WE DID
MAKE SUGGESTIONS. THAT AS IF
THIS GOES FORWARD IT'LL GO TO
PUBLIC SAFETY WE HAVE ASSEMBLY
JONES SAWYER WITH US- THE
COMMITTEE HERE- AND THE TWO
AREAS OF INTEREST- BEFORE
CONSIDERATION RAY GRATEFUL THAT
YOU'VE- ACCEPTED THE
CONSIDERATION OF THOSE
SUGGESTIONS- IS THAT. INSTEAD OF
IT BEING HOUSES OF THE UNIT BE
HELPED. SHEPHERD BE HOUSING
POLICY. BECAUSE THEY ALREADY
HAVE INVESTIGATORS IF
INVESTITORI. TASK FORCES
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY TASK FORCES
SO. THAT'S MORE THEIR AREA OF
FOCUS. AND AS WAS JUST DISCUSSED
RIGHT NOW- JUST MAKE IT CLEAR
THAT- YOU KNOW THE THAT. THE
UNIT CAN REFER CASES LABOUR
TRACTOR TRAFFICKING. TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE OR TO
DETAINEES AND THEY CAN DO WHAT
THEY SEE FIT. WITH WITH THOSE
REFERRALS- AND SERVE WITH THOSE
CLARIFICATIONS. HOPEFULLY THOSE
THINGS CAN BE WORKED OUT
LANGUAGE AND ALL THAT. AT PUBLIC
SAFETY- IT THIS MAKES IT OVER
THERE- AND I. REALLY APPRECIATE
YOU AND YOUR STAFF WORKED WITH
OURS ON THOSE ISSUES. I WILL
ALLOW- COMMISSIONER BUT DIDN'T
ON OUT. IT'S THAT- THERE WILL BE
A POINT OF CONTACT THAT WERE
CREATING WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
AND DOES RELATIONS SO IF OSHA I
WERE INTENTIONALLY ENSURING THAT
THEY'RE DIRECTING THOSE TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS SO WE CAN THEN
INVESTIGATE SO YOU ARE CORRECT
IN YOUR STATE FISHER SO ONE OF
ONE OF THE ISSUES WE DISCOVERED
AS WE WERE HAVING OUR HEARINGS
WAS THAT THERE WERE FOUR OR FIVE
DEPARTMENTS THAT WERE INVOLVED
POSSIBLY IN HUMAN TRAFFICKING
AND LABOR TRAFFICKING AND IT WAS
THE PROBLEM THE PROBLEM WAS THEY
WERE GOING LIKE THIS. RIGHT THEY
WERE MAKING THE CONNECTIONS AND
SO ON VICTIMS WOULD FALL THROUGH
THE CRACKS AND SO WHAT WE'RE
HOPING IS THAT WE CAN CENTRALIZE
IT A LITTLE BIT RIGHT THAT SOME
OF THAT WILL END IT WASN'T THE
PEOPLE THAT DEPARTMENT FOLKS
WERE INTERESTED IN DOING
SOMETHING RIGHT BUT DEPENDING ON
WHAT THEIR WORKLOAD WAS WHAT WAS
GOING ON INTERNALLY RIGHT AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT THEY FELT IT WAS
APPROPRIATE FOR THEM TO BE THE
ONES TO START SOMETHING AS
OPPOSED TO SOMEBODY ELSE AND SO.
THAT'S ONE OF THE WHAT WHY WE
MADE THE RECOMMENDATION COULD
YOU PUT IT SOMEWHERE TECHNIC
SOMEBODY RESPONSIBLE SO THAT
THAT KIND OF THE MISHAPS WILL
CONTINUE TO HAPPEN RIGHT THANK
YOU FOR ALL THAT RESEARCH FROM
THE COMMISSION STANDPOINT AS
WELL BRING IN THE- YOU KNOW
FOUNDATION FOR THIS BILL I THINK
IT'LL MAKE A HUGE DIFFERENCE-
HAPPY TO I THINK THERE'S A
MOTION AND A SECOND I'LL BE
HAPPY TO BE SUPPORTING IT AS
WELL AS IMPACTED AS COLD CAL
OSHA IS WITH ITS- WIDE RANGE OF
RESPONSIBILITIES. IN THIS IS I
HOPE THAT WE CAN FIND THAT AS
WELL THAT WOULD BE A. BUDGET
CONVERSATION. THANK THANK YOU
SUMMARY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
I THINK THAT OFTENTIMES WHEN WE
THINK OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
YOU'RE RIGHT COMMISSIONER WERE
ONLY THINKING OF SEX TRAFFICKING
AS OPPOSED TO LABOR TRAFFIC I
ALSO HAVE A BILL IN THIS IN THIS
SPACE AND IN LIGHT OF THAT I
WOULD IF YOU WOULD ALLOW IT I
WOULD LOVE TO BE LISTED AS A CO
AUTHOR OF YOUR BILL. ANY OTHER.
COMMENTS YES SOMEONE HAS ALSO
DONE DOES THE SPACE IT'S A MEANS
FRANKLY HEARTBREAKING- WHAT WHAT
WHAT PC SO MANY WORKERS GO
THROUGH- UNDER FALSE PRETENSES
AND JUST THE WAY THEY'RE TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF- IN SO I'M VERY
GRATEFUL TO YOU AND YOUR
SPONSORS. FOR TAKING ON BECAUSE
OF THE THERE'S ALWAYS A HEAVY
LEFT WHEN AND- YOU CREATE THE
UNIT THEN IT'S ABOUT A
REPLACEMENT AND THAT'S WHERE WE
START GETTING PUSHED BACK RIGHT.
IN BUT TO PUT I THINK IT'S A
VERY SMART MOVE TO GO IN THIS
DIRECTION ACTUALLY. FORMALLY
CREATE A UNIT- DESIGNED FOR
IDENTIFYING THIS KIND OF ABUSE.
I WOULD ALSO. LIKE TO BE ADDED
ON AS A CO AUTHOR AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK ON THIS- WE
DO HAVE A MOTION ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. CARILLO SECONDED BY SOME
AREAS. DR ON THOSE LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN ITEM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. A MADAM
SECTION OF TABLE ON AB EIGHTEEN
TWENTY PLEASE. QUESTION IS DO
PASSED TO PUBLIC. SAFETY
COMMITTEE KALRA. KALRA I BIGELOW
. BIGELOW AYE JONES SAWYER JUNE
SAWYER I. REYES I'D CHEN CHEN HI
YOU BOARD. WHAT I AGREE UP
CARILLO I. THIS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND THE CHAIR JONES SAWYER
WE DID BE TALK ABOUT WAS HAPPEN
YOU CAN- KNOW HOPEFULLY A LATE.
YEAH I. SENT HER- AB EIGHTEEN
FIFTY. WHEN YOU AND YOU AND YOUR
AND WITNESSES ARE READY TO GO
FEEL FREE TO BE IN TESTING ALL
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
COLLEAGUES ALWAYS GREAT TO SEE
YOU THIS FINE AFTERNOON. THIS
LEGISLATION ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTEEN FIFTY ONE IT SEEKS TO
ENSURE THAT ON HAUL TRUCK
DRIVERS WHO BRING THE TAYLOR WHO
BRING- SOME MATERIALS TO A
PUBLIC WORKS PROJECT SITE FOR
PAVING GRADING AND FILL. THAT
THEY'RE PAID- A PREVAILING WAGE
WHICH IS ALREADY THE CASE FOR
OFF PAUL TRUCKING WORK NO
EXISTING LAW REQUIRES THAT ALL
WORKERS ON A PUBLIC WORKS
PROJECT BE PAID- A PREVAILING
WAGE JUST LAST SUMMER A SERIES
OF CAL OF- THE SUPREME SINCE THE
SUPREME COURT. SOME DECISIONS
HERE IN OUR STATE CALIFORNIA
INJECTED SOME UNCERTAINTY ABOUT
WHETHER ON HAUL TRUCKING WORK
QUALIFIES FOR A PREVAILING WAGE.
AGAIN OFF ALL TRUCK DRIVERS WHO
PERFORM SIMILAR WORK TO ON HALL
TRUCK DRIVERS ARE ON AND BIG
USUALLY COVERED UNDER THE
PREVAILING WAGE REQUIREMENTS IN
LABOR CODE SECTION ONE SEVEN TWO
ZERO POINT THREE. THE CLEARLY
THE DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS WOULD BENEFIT FROM
GREATER CERTAINTY AS TO WHETHER
ON HAUL TRUCK DRIVERS ARE
COVERED. UNDER THIS LABOR CODE
SECTION MOVING FORWARD- SO THIS
LEGISLATION WILL SIMPLY CLARIFY
THAT A PUBLIC WORKS PROJECT
INCLUDES THE TRUCKING OF
MATERIALS FOR PAVING GRADING TO
FILL BOTH TO AND FROM. THE
PROJECT SITE FOR PURPOSES OF THE
PREVAILING WAGE REQUIREMENTS YOU
KNOW ON A PERSONAL NOTE. I CAN
TELL YOU THAT MANY TRUCK DRIVERS
IN THE DISTRICT I REPRESENT SUCH
AS YOUR DISTRICTS AS WELL ARE
STRUGGLING TO MAKE ENDS MEET.
AND THEY'RE DOING THEIR PART AND
PERFORMING THE POINT WORK TO
HELP BUILD OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
HOUSING ROADS AND THEY DESERVE
TO BE PAID- A PREVAILING WAGE
AND SO APPRECIATE YOUR TIME. AND
WITH ME HERE TO TESTIFY ARE NOT
BROAD- ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS PUBLIC
AFFAIRS COUNCIL AND STEW HELFER-
THE WESTERN- WITH THE WESTERN
REGION PRESENTED. FOR THE
TEAMSTERS BUT THE MATERIAL AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADE- THE DIVISION
THANK OF STRIKE YOU SO MUCH AS
ALWAYS WITNESSES UP TO TWO
MINUTES INSTRUCT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MAP BROUGHT
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEAMSTERS PUBLIC AFFAIRS COUNCIL
WE ARE THAT PROUD SPONSORS OF AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY ONE. AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RIVAS SAID THE BILL WOULD
PROVIDE PREVAILING WAGE COVERAGE
FOR THE ON HALL OF MATERIALS.
FOR PAVING GRADING AND FILL- AND
THIS LIKE SAID WITH INSPIRED BY
A TRUE OF K. CASE LAST SOME.
BUSTER MENDOZA AND COULD NOT
NOW- AND THERE'S SOME A LITTLE
BIT OF STATUTORY AMBIGUITY
ABOUT. WHAT ON HOW WORK IS
COVERED FOR THE PURPOSES OF
PREVAILING WAGE SO THEY KICKED
IT BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE AND
HERE WE ARE. WE'VE HEARD THE
CONCERNS OPPOSITION- AND HAVE
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THEM
TOWARD THE FINAL VERSION OF THE
BILL THAT THEY MAY FIND A LITTLE
BIT MORE PALATABLE. AND WITH ME
TODAY IS TO HEALTH FOR YOU AGAIN
IS THE WESTERN REPRESENTATIVE.
AT THE TEAMSTERS BUILDING
MATERIAL AND CONSTRUCTION TRADE
DIVISION TO PROVIDE SHORT
COMMENTS IN FAVOR OF THE BILL OR
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TO HELP. IN MR
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I
PROMISE MATT AND MYSTERY OF US
THAT I WOULD TRY TO KEEP IT
SHORT ANYBODY THAT KNOWS ME
REALLY REALIZE THAT'S GONNA TAKE
SOME STRUGGLE ON MY- I'LL DO THE
BEST THAT I CAN. IF YOU LOOK AT
THE OLD PREVAILING WAGE
DETERMINATIONS FOR THE CRAFT OF
DRIVER IT'S QUITE CLEAR. SINCE
TWO THOUSAND AND NINE
APPROXIMATELY. IT STATED ON THE
DETERMINATION FALLING TO. AND
FROM THE SIDE OF CONSTRUCTION.
IS COVERED AT THAT POINT. MR
BROADEST CERTAINLY MENTION THE
TRILOGY WASN'T THE STAR WARS
TRILOGY BUT IT WAS ANOTHER
TRILOGY. THAT TOSSED SOME OF
THIS INTO QUESTION AND WHAT WE
ACTUALLY HAVE HERE IS PEOPLE
THAT A YEAR AND A HALF AGO WERE
DESIGNATED AS ESSENTIAL WORKERS
HAULING MATERIALS FOR PUBLIC
WORKS PROJECTS ARE NOW BEING.
REGULATED BACK TO SOME SUB CLASS
KNOWN AS THEY'RE JUST DRIVERS.
THESE ARE MEN AND WOMEN HARD
WORKING MEN AND WOMEN THAT ARE
STRUGGLING TO SAFELY PERFORM THE
WORK NECESSARY IN GETTING
MATERIALS TO AND FROM PUBLIC
WORKSITE. THEY'RE NOT BEING PAID
. WAGE RATES WITHOUT PUBLIC
WORK- WITHOUT PREVAILING WAGE
RATES THEIR WAGES ARE ALWAYS IN
A CONSTANT STATE OF FLUX THIS
WILL ADD SOME STABILITY TO THE
WORLD AND WELL ACTUALLY SAID
SOME STABILITY TO THE PROJECTS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
YOU WON'T SEE THE POTENTIAL
ISSUES WHERE YOU'VE SEEN IN SOME
OTHER AREAS NORTH OF THE BORDER
WHERE THE WAGE RATES AND WHAT
NOT COULD BE CALLED INTO
QUESTION. SO WITH THAT I REALLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
AND TO MOVE THIS FORWARD AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THAT'S
ABOUT AS SHORT AS I CAN KEEP.
THANK YOU FOR SHE ADDED- IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE AUDIENCE IN
SUPPORT OF AB. EIGHTEEN FIFTY
ONE. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MIKE
WEST ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. SCOGGINS OFF
TEAMSTERS LOCAL EIGHT FIFTY
THREE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RIGHT LET'S GO OVER TO THE
PHONES WHICH MODERATOR ONE OF
THE PHONES IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTY FIFTY ONE. DO YOU TO
EXPRESS YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE. ONCE-AGAIN THE COMMANDERS ONE AND
THEN OF ZERO. WE'LL GO FIRST TO
LINE ONE THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MITCH SNIDER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION ALSO
EXPORT THANK YOU. LINE ONE A ONE
. YES GOOD AFTERNOON MY HEARING
WELL TO REMEMBER AT THE
TEAMSTERS LOCAL ONE EXPECT AND I
SUPPORT EIGHTY EIGHTEEN FIFTY
ONE. THANK YOU. WITH ON LINE ONE
SEVEN. LINE ONE OH SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS THAT
EVEN AT YOU ON THE NUMBER OF THE
TEAMSTERS LOCAL EIGHT FIFTY
THREE. AND I AM AND- AND- IN
FAVOR OF BILL EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHT
ONE EIGHT FIVE ONE. THANK YOU.
NEXT WE HAVE LINED ONE OH TWO.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JOHN
DAVIDSON REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION DIVISION IF THEY'RE
GOING TO ALSO FORTY TWO A
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. LINE ONE FORTY FIVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT THE COLOR JOAQUIN
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
STATE PIPE TRADES COUNCIL
QUESTIONS STATE COUNCIL OF SHEET
METAL WORKERS INTERNATIONAL
UNION OF ELEVATOR CONSTRUCTORS
REGISTERING OUR STRONG SUPPORT
BIRTH ON THE BILL ONE EIGHT FIVE
ONE. THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE.
ONE HUNDRED. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS CAESAR MORE HOUSE I'M A
MEMBER OF TEAMSTERS LOCAL NINE
EIGHTY SIX AND I SUPPORT
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN FIFTY
ONE. THANK YOU. AT THIS TIME
THEY'RE NOT FOR LINES IN Q.
THANK YOU- OKAY OPPOSITION. YEAH. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
VERSE TODD BLOOM SIGN FOR THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION OF FIRSTLY I'D LIKE
TO STATE I RESPECT THE INTENT OF
THE BILL TO PROVIDE A BETTER
WAGE A BETTER LIFE FOR YOUR
MEMBERS I TRULY APPRECIATE THAT-
S. C. C. A. AS IN ALL UNION
ASSOCIATION OF CIVIL ENGINEERING
CONTRACTORS OTHER OPPOSED TO
EIGHTEEN FIFTY ONE TO BE CLEAR
SCCA IS NOT OPPOSED TO HIGHER
WAGES. SEC'S SCCA MEMBERS PAY
THEIR EMPLOYEES A LIVING WAGE
THE MASTER LABOR AGREEMENTS FOR
AN OPERATING ENGINEER AS AN
EXAMPLE OF THE STARTS AT FIFTY
DOLLARS AN HOUR- ADDITIONALLY
CONTRACTORS PAY AN ADDITIONAL
THIRTY DOLLARS AN HOUR A FOR
HEALTH WELFARE AND PENSION
BENEFITS OF ITS EIGHTY DOLLARS
PER HOUR FOR AN ENTRY LEVEL
OFFERING A- OPERATING ENGINEER.
THE ISSUE FOR SCCA IS NOT THE
WAGE THE ISSUE IS THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
CONTRACTOR AND SUPPLIER. THE
CONTRACTOR HAS NO CONTROL OVER
THE LABOR CONDITIONS CONDITIONS
OF A SUPPLIER BUT THE
APPLICATION OF A PUBLIC WORK FOR
THIS SERVICE TRIGGERS THE
POTENTIAL LABOR CODE LIABILITIES
FOR UNPAID WAGES. THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN A
CONTRACTOR AND THE SUPPLIER IS
NOT A CONSTRUCTION CONTRACT IT
IS A PURCHASE ORDER. SCCA
RESPECTFULLY RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR NO VOTE FOR THAT
REASON THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU IN THE ROOM IN
OPPOSITION GREAT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE PHILIP IF WENT THIS
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATED
GENERAL CONTRACTORS OF
CALIFORNIA WE DON'T HAVE IN MY
APOLOGIES TO THE AUTHOR WE DON'T
HAVE A POSITION FORMALIZED YET
OR LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE WILL
GET TOGETHER TOMORROW BUT WE'RE
PRETTY CERTAIN THAT WILL BE
OPPOSING THIS MEASURE AS WELL.
LIKE MY COLLEAGUE- TODD BLUE
SIGN- WE ARE THE MAJORITY IN OUR
CASE MAJORITY UNIONIZED
CONTRACTOR ASSOCIATION WE BUILD
ALL YOUR HEAVY HIGHWAY CIVIL
UNDERGROUND UTILITIES AND I JUST
WANT TO UNDERSCORE THE POINT
MADE BY MR BLOOM SIGN ABOUT THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
CONTRACTOR AND THE SUPPLIER. WE
DON'T HAVE CONTROL OVER THESE
EMPLOYEES UP BUT ANOTHER
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE THAT I'VE
HEARD FROM OUR CONTRACTORS IS
THAT THERE ARE VERY FEW PLACES
WHERE CONTRACT. AVAIL THEMSELVES
OF THE DISADVANTAGED BUSINESS
ENTERPRISE GOALS SET BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND IN MANY OF THESE
BIDS ONE OF THE FEW PLACES THAT
WERE ABLE TO FIND THAT IS IN THE
SUPPLY CHAIN. SO IF WE START IN
ADVERT ONLY PUSHING THAT SUPPLY
CHAIN TO A PLACE WHERE IT'S NO
LONGER INDEPENDENT BUSINESS WE
ARE VERY SMALL RECOURSE IN ORDER
TO SATISFY THAT REQUIREMENT SO
FOR THOSE REASONS I THINK WE'RE
GOING TO BE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE BUT I WILL. FORMALIZE
OUR OPINION FOR YOU TOMORROW
THANK YOU I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
. IS ANYONE IN THE ROOM IN
OPPOSITION. MORE GO HEAD TO THE
PHONES THIS MODERATOR AND WE'RE
ON THE PHONE IN OPPOSITION TO AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY ONE. YOU TO STATE
YOUR OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL YOU
MAY PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
AGAIN THAT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO.
WE'LL GO FIRST TO LINE THE ONE
ALL THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON STACEY
KEATING WITH THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
AGAIN WE ACTUALLY DON'T HAVE A
POSITION ON THIS BILL WE CAME IN
A LITTLE LATE JUST WANTED TO
THANK THE AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF
FOR TAKING TIME TO DISCUSS OUR
CONCERNS WITH THAT- LAST WEEK
OVER THIS BILL AND- TAKING THE
TIME TO REVIEW OUR CONCERNS THE
ONE TAKE A POSITION UNTIL WE
HAVE HAD TO DISCUSS FURTHER AND
WE INTEND TO CONTINUE DOING
THAT. AFTER HIS HEARING BUT JUST
WANTED TO MAKE SURE WE TAKE THE
OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. WINE. ONE FORTY TWO. GOOD
AFTERNOON SIR NUMBERS CLICK
BLACKBURN CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE WESTERN STATES TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION TO A.
B. EIGHTEEN FIFTY ONE FOR THE
REASONS STATED IN OUR OPPOSITION
MATTER. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WITH THAT THERE ARE NO
FOR THE LINES IN Q. I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE WE DO HAVE A
MOTION ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
. A SUMMARY JONES SAWYER I'VE
BEEN IN JUST PUT PRETTY AUTHOR
OR FOR WITNESSES COULD YOU- WHAT
MISTER PHILLIP DAVIS AND- BUT
BOOSTING BROUGHT UP. BOB CAN YOU
CLARIFY IF IT SEEMS LIKE THERE
MIGHT BE SOME. TO MIGHT AT AN
EQUITABLE SOLUTION TO IT FOR
CLARIFICATION SO THAT YOU BOTH
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
DO BECAUSE IT DOES SOUND LIKE
THEY'RE NOT OPPOSED TO WHAT
YOU'RE DOING MAYBE HOW YOU'RE
GETTING TO IT. AND IF THAT MAKES
ANY SENSE- CAN YOU HELP. CLARIFY
FOR THE COMMITTEE SURE I'M HAPPY
TO ACT I ANSWER THAT QUESTION- I
WOULD YOU KNOW I SPOKE WITH MR
FUENTES MAYBE A DAY OR TWO AGO
ABOUT HIS CONCERNS WITH. REGARDS
TO A HI THERE DISADVANTAGE
BUSINESS ENTITIES- AND YOU KNOW
WE SUPPORT DOES THIS FOCUS ON
PROJECTS IN WOULD ARGUE THAT
LIFTING THE PREVAILING WAGE
WOULD NOT IMPACT THEIR STATUS AS
A D. B. E. IT MAY HOWEVER RAISE
WAGES FOR THEM. I'M WHICH WOULD
OBVIOUSLY BE A GOOD THING SO YOU
KNOW WE'RE WE'RE SCRATCHING OUR
HEADS A LITTLE BIT AT THAT ONE-
STEVE I DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAVE.
A POINT HI TO MISTER BLOOM
STEIN'S COMMENTS ABOUT GENERAL
LIABILITY. MY UNDERSTANDING. IS
THAT. THERE WAS A QUESTION AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT THIS TALKS ABOUT
SUPPLIERS OR ACTUAL TRANSPORTERS
OKAY THE TRANSPORTERS OF THE MEN
AND WOMEN THE HARD WORKING MEN
AND WOMEN THE DRIVE AND OPERATE
THE VEHICLES TO BRING THE
MATERIALS EITHER FROM A SOURCE
OR TO A SOURCE THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT THE SUPPLIER THAT ACTUALLY
TAKES MATERIAL OUT OF THE GROUND
WERE FORMULATES IT AT A BATCH
PLANT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE DRIVING THE
TRUCKS. ON THE ROAD. AT THE END
LIKE I SAID IN MY OPENING
COMMENTS WERE MORE THAN HAPPY TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION TRY TO RESOLVE SOME
OF THOSE ISSUES WHERE WE CAN
WE'RE OBVIOUSLY. OPEN TO TALKING
TO ANY STAKEHOLDERS THAT REYES I
ANY OTHER ISSUES. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. BOB BASED
ON MY EXPERTISE WITH THE AUTHOR
AND THE SPONSORS AS WELL AS
OPPOSITION I KNOW THAT IF THERE
IS AN OPPORTUNITY- TO COME
TOGETHER AND FIND A PATH FORWARD
I'M SURE YOU ALL FIND IT AND-
WISH YOU LUCK IN THAT I REALLY
DO APPRECIATE THIS BILL- AND NOT
JUST THE INTENTION BUT THE NEED
AS WELL- AND SO WITH THAT WE DO
HAVE A MOTION OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS DO PASS OF THE
RECOMMENDATION TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS FROM A SOME
AMERICA DO SECONDED BY SOME
MEMBERS JONES SAWYER- THE
MINISTRY THIS IS LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECT ASPEN ABOUT MR. THANK
YOU. THAT WAS ACTUALLY. I THINK
THE ROLE ON AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY
ONE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA FIVE KALRA
I'D BIGELOW. BIGELOW NO JONES
SAWYER I WOULD UNDERSTAND IT
THEY'LL GET TOGETHER AND TALK.
WHERE I REYES FIVE REYES I'D
CHEN CHEN I WARD FIVE WARD HI
CAREER CARILLO HI THAT BILLS OUT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU UP NEXT WE HAVE FILE
ITEM FIVE AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY SIX
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER. A
SIMILAR WHENEVER YOU'RE READY GO
AHEAD AND PROCEED. I GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY SIX CODIFIES
A RECENT DEPARTMENT OF INVESTOR
RELATIONS PREVAILING WAGE
DETERMINATION TO CLARIFY THAT
STREET SWEEPING IS INCLUDED IN
THE DEFINIION OF PUBLIC WORKS
REQUIRES A PAYMENT OF PREVAILING
WAGE STREET SWEEPING IS A
CRITICAL PUBLIC SAFETY AND ROAD
MAINTENANCE TASKS THAT INVOLVE
THE CLEARING OF THE BREEZE FOR
PUBLIC STREETS AND ROADWAYS. IN
AN EFFORT TO KEEP OUR ROADS SAFE
FOR PUBLIC USE IN OCTOBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE DEPARTMENT
INDUSTRIALIZATION FOUND THAT
STREET SWEEPING IS ROUTINE AND
RECURRING WORK THAT KEEPS PUBLIC
STREETS OF FACILITIES IN A SAFE
IT CONTINUALLY USABLE CONDITION
FOR PUBLIC USE. AN EFFORT TO
BRING CLOSURE TO THIS MATTER AB
H. NAY SIX WOULD CODIFY STREETS
WOULD BE MAINTENANCE AS PUBLIC
WORKS WHICH IN RETURN WOULD
ASSURE THE FAIR PAYMENT FOR THE
WORKERS PERFORMING THIS CRITICAL
WORK. HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY
SUPPORT IS MATT CRIMMINS THE
PLANE OF ATTOCK INTERNATIONAL
UNION OF OPERATING ENGINEERS THE
SPONSOR OF CERTAIN SPONSORS OF
AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY SIX. THANK
THAT CORRECTIVE EMOTIONS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH COOPER AND- MR
CLEMENS. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MATT CRIMMINS HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA ABOUT A
CONFERENCE OF OPERATING
ENGINEERS WE ARE THE PROUD
SPONSORS OF AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
SIX AND ARE SINCERELY
APPRECIATIVE PERSON A MEMBER
COOPER CARING THIS PROPOSAL. AB
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY SIX IS INTENDED
TO PROVIDE CLARITY TO
CONTRACTORS AWARDING AGENCIES
AND LABOR COMPLIANCE ENTITIES.
AROUND THE ISSUE OF STREET
SWEEPING WEIGHT MAINTENANCE
WHICH AS OF THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALLUDED TO IS CRUCIAL TO THE- TO
PRESERVE THE FUNCTIONALITY OF
OUR EXISTING PUBLIC ROADS. AS
YOU ALSO MENTION THE DEPARTMENT
OF INDUSTRIALIZATION HAS LOOKED
AT THIS TASK NUMEROUS TIMES OF
THE LAST TWO DECADES. AND HAS
CONSISTENTLY FOUND THAT THIS IS
A CRUCIAL ROAD MAINTENANCE TASKS
THAT SHOULD PAY THE PREVAILING
WAGE. I'M AGAIN IN TEN YEARS
PROVIDE CLARITY I WILL BE BRIEF
AND WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- ANYONE IN THE ROOM IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
SIX PLEASE- POST MICROPHONE. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MIKE WEST ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL ALSO
OWNS FOUR. THANK YOU. STEW
HELPER WEST REGION REP
INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD OF
TEAMSTERS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
TODDLING SIGNED SEVEN CALIFORNIA
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THIS GARDENS ALL OF
TEAMSTERS LOCAL EIGHT FIFTY
THREE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MAP BROUGHT
FOR THE TEAMSTERS AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. HI MISS
MODERATOR IF YOU CAN CHECK ON
THE PHONE LINES THOSE IN SUPPORT
OF AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY SIX. IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS YOUR
POSITION AND SUPPORT ME PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AGAIN
USING THE TELEPHONE KEYPAD TO ME
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE WILL
GO TO LINE A ONE THIRTY NINE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MITCH SNIDER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO EXPORT.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE LINE ONE
FORTY SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
KILEY JOAQUIN CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE BY TRADE
COUNCIL CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS AND WESTERN STATE
COUNCIL OF SHEET METAL WORKERS
ADDITIONALLY REGISTRAR SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NO FURTHER
LINES INTO AT THIS TIME I THINK
YOU IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
SIX. SOME MODERATORS CAN GO TO
THE PHONE TO SEE IF ANYONE'S
CALL. ANYONE IS CALLED IN IN
OPPOSITION TO AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
SIX. THE STATE A POSITION OF
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AGAIN USING
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. THERE ARE NO LINES IN Q. OKAY.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
WE DO HAVE A MOTION ANY COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS FOR SENATE MEMBER
COOPER. YEAH AS A RESULT OF IT
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS FOR
I I'M ACTUALLY I WORK FOR THE
CITY WILL DELAY FOR. FOR SEVERAL
DECADES AND I WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC WORKS WOULD
HAVE A STREET MAINTENANCE STREET
SERVICE STREET SWEEPING. I
ALWAYS THOUGHT. THEY WERE ALL
UNDER HIS ARM. SO I'M GLAD YOU
FOUND YEAH THIS AND MR GRUBER
I'M GLAD YOU BROUGHT IT FORWARD
BECAUSE- IT. SHOULD ALREADY BE.
THAT'S OUR I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THANK YOU. ANYONE THAT'S BEEN
DELIVERED. HEARING KNOWS THAT MR
JOHNSON HAS HAD A LOT OF JOBS.
HE CAN CONNECT TO A LOT OF THE
BILLS THAT COME BEFORE US ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
WELL AS YOU SEE THE THEME TODAY
HOW FAR BILLS HAVE DEALT WITH
PUBLIC WORKS MAKING SURE WE HAVE
PROPER WOULD NOT JUST WAGES BUT
SKILL LEVEL FOR THOSE THAT ARE
DOING CRITICAL FUNCTIONS FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES. AND WE CAN TALK
AMONGST OURSELVES BY BATCH IF
YOU GO TO OUR RESIDENTS AND AS
OUR RESIDENTS FOR STREET
SWEEPING IS A CRITICAL FUNCTION
BROADBAND AS- THEY WERE A 100%
OF THE VOTE AGREE WITH THAT AND
SO. I WANT TO THANK SENATOR
COOPER FOR BRING THIS FORWARD-
WE HAVE A MOTION FROM WE HAVE
ALREADY MADE THE RECOMMENDATION
TO PASTOR PROCS- FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES SECONDED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES SAWYER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER WAS LIKE
TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU. MADAM SECRETARY COULD
TAKE THE WHEEL ON A. B. EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY SIX PLEASE. MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROACH. KALRA FIVE
KALRA I'D BIGELOW. WITH RICK.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING JONES SAWYER
HI JONES SAWYER AYE REYES AYE
REYES AYE CHAN. CHEN HI WARD BY
WARD I AGREE OKAY CARILLO HI BUT
THAT DOES NOT THANK YOU SENATOR. IN THE LAST- BILLS FILE ITEM
SIX WHICH IS AB. NINETEEN FORTY
NINE. FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW.
NO SIR SO WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND. OFF TO A GOOD START
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW THANK YOU
VERY MUCH RESEARCHER AND
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE IN HELPING TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE BASIC
PROTECTIONS WITH RESPECT TO
HELPING INDIVIDUALS CARE FOR
THEIR LOVED ONES IN A TIME OF
LOS EVERY. HAVE RECALL YOU SEE
HER ALSO HERE SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU FIVE
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARIE GO
YOSHIHARA POLICY DIRECTOR FOR
THE CALIFORNIA PLANET LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE PROUD CO
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL ALONG WITH
CRIME SURVIVORS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE LEGAL AID AT WORK AND
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES
UNFORTUNATELY OUR WITNESS
COULDN'T BE HERE- TRAVELED TO
THE CAPITOL TO TESTIFY BUT- I
WOULD LIKE TO READ HER
TESTIMONY- WHICH REALLY SHOWS
WHY THIS BILL IS SO IMPORTANT.
SO GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS LETTER HAS BEEN
WRITTEN TO EXPRESS MY SUPPORT
FOR A BI NINETEEN FORTY NINE THE
BEREAVEMENT LEAVE ACT I AM
YVONNE TRIES A SURVIVOR MOTHER
GRANDMOTHER COMMUNITY MEMBER AND
THE FOUNDER OF THE MOTHER'S
VOICE AN ORGANIZATION THAT WORKS
TO PROVIDE SUPPORT TO MOTHERS
WHO HAVE LOST CHILREN TO GUN
VIOLENCE. I'M SADDENED BY THE
FACT THAT THERE CONTINUES TO BE
A LACK OF UNDERSTANDING AND CARE
FOR FAMILIES WHO HAVE LOST LOVED
ONES TO VIOLENCE I LOST MY SON
ON AUGUST TWENTY FIRST TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN DUE TO HIM
BEING MURDERED. THIS WAS THE
FIRST TIME IN MY LIFE THAT
SOMEONE SO CLOSE TO ME WAS
KILLED AND THIS WASN'T JUST ANY
PERSON IT WAS MY BABY THIS WAS A
TRULY SCARY TIME FOR MY FAMILY
AND I PARTLY BECAUSE WE DIDN'T
KNOW WHO KILLED HIM AND PARTLY
BECAUSE HE WAS MURDERED. I TRIED%
MY BEST TO RETURN TO WORK AFTER
THREE DAYS HOWEVER THE PAIN AND
TRAUMA CAUSED ME TO START
DECIDING AND DEPRESSION YOU SEE
I WAS ONLY GIVEN THREE DAYS OFF
OF WORK AT THE TIME I DID NOT
UNDERSTAND THAT IT WOULD TAKE
FOURTEEN DAYS TO GET HIS BODY
BACK FROM THE CORONER'S OFFICE.
AND MORE TIME TO FOCUS ON
FUNERAL ARRANGEMENTS IT IS SO
HARD TO FOCUS WHEN TRYING TO
BURY YOUR CHILD OR FAMILY MEMBER
AFTER THREE DAYS THE HEALING
PROCESS HAD NOT STARTED AT A-
THIS POINT. I WAS FULLY ENGAGED
IN THE TRAUMA AND I LOST MY JOB.
SO NOW NOT ONLY DID I STILL HAVE
TO BURY MY CHILD BUT I ALSO HAD
TO FIND A WAY TO CONTINUE
FINANCIALLY SUPPORTING MYSELF.
AND MY FAMILY. I SUPPORT AND
PRAY THAT YOU PASS THIS BILL TO
ENSURE THAT FAMILIES HAVE A
RIGHT TO UNPAID BEREAVEMENT
LEAVE. THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE
WORKERS WITH THE BASIC LEVEL OF
PROTECTION DURING A MOMENT OF
IMMENSE HARDSHIP. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND- I JUST WANT TO
THINK IS THE ONLY MEMBER LOW FOR
YOUR DEDICATION AND COMMITMENT
TO THIS ISSUE THIS IS WHY OUR
ORGANIZATIONS ARE SO DEDICATED
TO THIS. THIS ISSUE AS WELL
UNFORTUNATELY THESE
HEARTBREAKING STORIES ARE TOO
COMMON- THAT WE HEAR FROM. AND
THIS LEAVE LAW FILLS A CRITICAL
GAP THAT WE HAVE AND WE HAVE
LEAVE LAWS THAT ALLOW WORKERS TO
TAKE LEAVE TO CARE FOR.
SERIOUSLY ILL FAMILY MEMBERS BUT
THEN AS SOON AS A FAMILY MEMBER
PASSES AWAY. THE RIGHT TO TAKE
THAT LEAVE ENDS. AND WE KNOW
THAT THERE ARE GOOD EMPLOYERS
THAT DO PROVIDE BEREAVEMENT
LEAVE BUT- WE THINK EVERY WORKER
SHOULD HAVE HAVE THIS RIGHT TO
TAKE THAT TIME OFF DURING THIS.
IMMENSELY HARD TIME IN THEIR
LIFE- SO FAR THAT- YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND I DO I
THINK THE AUTHORS SPONSORS FOR
THE FLEXIBILITY REGARDING
WITNESS HAS FINALLY REVERTED
BACK TO IN PERSON AND- SO. I DO
WANT TO THANK YOU AND THAT
STATEMENT WAS VERY POWERFUL
THANK YOU FOR SHARING. THAT
STATEMENT. IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
IN THE ROOM IS IT IN THE ROOM IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN FORTY
NINE. CHRIS RESPONSES PART SEVEN
OF THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THIS MODERATORS ANYONE ON
THE PHONE IN SUPPORT OF AB
NINETEEN FORTY NINE. THANK YOU
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AGAIN
USING YOUR PHONE THAT'S ONE AND
THEN ZERO. WE'LL THE FIRST
ONLINE ONE FORTY ONE. YEAH GOOD
AFTERNOON REBECCA GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE ONE
TWENTY SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT
THE TERROR CAPPING THEM OFF THEN
BUT BEGINNING THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
. NINE ONE THIRTY NINE. SEARCH
OUR MEMBERS THAT TIGER WOODS
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION ALSO
. THANK YOU. LINE ONE FORTY NINE
. GOOD AFTERNOON CARE NUMBER
THAT THE CUSTOMER ON BEHALF OF
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES PROUD CO
SPONSOR AND FROM THE SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ONE FIFTY. IN BEHALF
OF THE CHARM CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES NETWORK INSTRUCTOR FOR
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ONE TWELVE
HOPE. THIS IS KATIE WATER SMITH
WITH THE CALIFORNIA WORK AND
FAMILY COALITION WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN FORTY
NINE THANK YOU THANK YOU. BRIAN
ONE OLD FOR. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBER WOULD BE GRANTED
YOU ARE KEEN ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY JUSTICE
AND CRIME SURVIVORS FOR SAFETY
AND JUSTICE HOW COSPONSOR OF AB
NINETEEN FORTY NINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NINE ONE FIFTY ONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN RICK MY
NAME IS IN THE LOCAL ERA PERFECT
LET CALIFORNIA AND I'M CALLING
IN STOCK OR IF YOU NEED THE
NINETEEN FORTY NINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. BLIGNAUT. ONE OH
EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON CHEN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS TINA
RODRIGUEZ I'M IN FRESNO
CALIFORNIA AND I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB ONE NINE
FOUR NINE. THANK YOU. THE LION
AT ONE FORTY EIGHT. AB WHICHIT
FROM LEGAL AID AT WORK A CO
SPONSOR CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE. ONE
FIFTY TWO. HI THIS IS JOE
CONTENT FROM PUBLIC COUNCIL ALSO
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
ONE NINE FOUR NINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND WITH THAT THERE
ARE NO FURTHER LINES IN Q. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- IS THERE ANYONE
HERE IN OPPOSITION. MISTER
MODERATOR FINGER THE PHONE TO
SEE IF IT WAS CALLED IN
OPPOSITION AB NINETEEN FORTY
NINE. IN JUNE THE STATE
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN
THE COMMANDERS ONE AND THEN ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. YOU
THERE ARE NO LINES IN Q. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH BEFORE
I BRING IT TO THE OTHER MEMBERS
AS A ONE QUESTION. WHAT ONE
QUESTION FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. WHAT IS
THIS A PAID IS THIS PAID OR
UNPAID LEAVE. MISTER HERE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF OUR KNOWLEDGE
AND THAT THIS IS UNPAID
BEREAVEMENT LEAVE AT THE BILL
BEFORE US IS UNPAID VERY
GREATLY- AND- BOBBY WISH TO
STRENGTHEN THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE IT PAID WE RECOGNIZE THE
SPECIFIC HARDSHIPS AND IN THAT
GOOD SPIRIT WE HOPE THAT THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY WOULD ALSO
COME IN STRONG SUPPORT AND
RECOGNIZING THAT THIS IS UNPAID.
LEAVE AND TO HELP ENSURE THAT WE
PROVIDE AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE WE
CAN CARE FOR OUR LOVED ONES IN
THEIR GREATEST TIME OF NEED
THANK YOU FOR THAT FURTHER
CLARIFICATION BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT'S BEEN A VERY OF THE
VETERAN TO READ THAT A LOT OVER
THE YEARS BECAUSE THERE SEEMS TO
BE CONFUSION AT TIMES SO
APPRECIATE THAT ANY OTHER FOR
THE QUESTIONS COME. AS A MEMBER
BIGELOW. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND- I FIND MYSELF IN A
PRECARIOUS POSITION HERE I I'M
SUPPORTED AND IN SOME PARTS OF
THE BILL IN SOME PARTS AYE. I
JUST CAN'T QUITE GET ACROSS THE
STATE TO HELP YOU ON THIS- BUT
THAT THAT ONE OF THE BIG ISSUES
IS ISSUES IS- CLEARLY THIS IS
FOR FIVE DAYS OF BEREAVEMENT
LEAVE BUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE PROVIDES THREE. SO
SHOULD THERE BE A CONSISTENCY IN
ACTION NOT JUST FOR PRIVATE
BUSINESSES BUT FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND ALL ITS IN A
DEBATE OVER PIECE- OR- IS DOING
BUSINESS WITH SHOULD THAT NOT BE
A REQUIREMENT THAT EXIST
THROUGHOUT THE WHOLE. ENTIRETY
OF THE SYSTEM THE SECOND IS. CAN
THERE BE AS THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD SOME CLARIFICATION OR
MAYBE STE. STRICTLY NOT STRICT
STRAIGHT DIRECTION THAT WOULD
HELP. SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE
FRIVOLOUS LAWSUITS THAT ARE
CREATED BECAUSE THERE CAN BE
AMBIGUITY IN THIS BILL. WHERE
SOMEBODY MAY NOT INTERPRET. OUR
FEEL THAT THEY'VE BEEN HARMED
WHEN IN FACT THEY REALLY HAVEN'T
REALLY HAS TO BE SOME WAY TO.
REALLY STYMIE THAT SO THE SMALL
BUSINESSES WHILE THIS BILL DOES
NOT AFFECT EMPLOYERS THE FOR OR
LESS IT DOESN'T. AFFECT THOSE
AFTER THAT AND THAT THAT COULD
BE VERY. DAMAGING TO THEM AND
THEIR BOTTOM LINE IN FACT ME
PUTTING OUT OF BUSINESS SO.
MAYBE AS IT WAS FOR YOU CAN
ADDRESS THAT YOU DON'T HAVE TO
ADDRESS. I FIND MYSELF WHERE I
CAN'T SUPPORT IT TODAY. BUT YEAH
AND I'M UNDERSTANDING SOME OF
THOSE THAT THIS WOULD APPLY TO
ALL EMPLOYERS INCLUDING PUBLIC
SECTOR EMPLOYERS. AND IT IT
DOESN'T SAY THAT. YOU MIGHT WANT
TO CLARIFY THAT THAT'S WHY I
OKAY. HELLO WE HAVE A IF AS YOU-
WELL NOTED THE BILL FAMILY VIDEO
IF THERE'S A MEDIATION- INCLUDED
AS WELL. FILE IN THIS- OKAY TO
THE CHAIR IF I MIGHT JUST
RESPONDING CLOSING. IF I MIGHT
MEDICARE YEAH WOULD LOVE THE
SAYS THE FAMILY HOUSING A
FURTHER QUESTION I WAS I WAS
GONNA MENTION THE MEAT IF
REQUIRES MEDIATION PRIOR
LITIGATION BUT- ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. OKAY SO
WE DO HAVE A- MOTION FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES SECONDED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN. THERE
IS A DO PASS TO JUDICIARY. OF
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE
COMMITTEE- AND SO I'M GOING TO.
HAND IT BACK OVER TO THE AUTHOR
FOR ANY FINAL COMMENTS GOOD OR
ANSWERING QUESTIONS. I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- MISTER CHAIR AND-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILL LOOK FOR TO
THE PARTNERSHIPS THAT YOU ASKED
THAT. QUESTION HE WAS A MEMBER
OF THE- I WELCOME YOUR INSIGHTS
AS WELL TOO IF YOU HAVE A STRONG
RECOMMENDATION SYSTEM FOR THE
BILL. I WILL WELCOME THAT SO YOU
GET YOUR SUPPORT AND I HOPE THAT
THIS ENJOYS BIPARTISAN PARTNER
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. THANK
YOU. MADAM SECRETARY OF TO TAKE
ROLE. ON THE VOTE FOR NINE AB
NINETEEN FORTY NINE. MOTION IS
TO PASS TO JUDICIARY KALRA AYE
KALRA AYE BIGELOW. BIGELOW NO
JONES SAWYER BY JONES SAWYER AYE
REYES HI REYES AYE CHAN CHAN I
WARD WARD HI CARILLO. CARILLO I
WRITE THE BILLS THAT WE HAVE NO
ADULT GOOD JOB VERY EVERYONE WAS
HERE VOTES. WELL I LOVE IT I
LOVE MY COMMITTEE. AT AND
GLASSES AND SUBSTITUTES TODAY.
WE'RE ON OUR POINT THANK YOU
NEEDS TO TURN. OKAY.